[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
all right round what's going on
your boy back with a new keyboard
and hopefully a continuous stream what's
going on
let me know how my levels are sounding
right now akw
well well well yeah yeah hustling
motivate what's going on
qti grizzly what's up night beard happy
boring day
night bed you know what i'm saying let's
go thank you thank you sir
thank you hustle appreciate that you're
saying that short life
brian motor what's going on lord metro
you already know what it is vanilla
vanilla gorilla i like that staccato
what's going on salute yeah
toto dope sticking how many knees you've
taken today
you're gonna be in this bag you know i'm
saying the man with the play
69 eagles fan what up
what's going on i'm a little brother
right there you know what i'm saying
judah 144. yeah man i appreciate y'all
up here here early you know i always
appreciate y'all got attic in the
building
talk to the people if you're still next
to your computer what's going on
you know that addy gotta fly to the
camera so you feeling itself
i'm just trying to figure out
that's good oh man lloyd metro two
dollar super chat stream lasted like the
dream cat yeah yo
let me explain how i was depressed
bro i was legit depressed for that but
like
i'm like why all my streams my my stuff
won't malfunction on the sega journey i
got planned but
we're gonna be back in the building
we're gonna be back in the building
that's that's not gonna stop
you know i mean shout out to razer
products who hopefully keep me through
no shout out i ain't gonna do that but
no shout out to other products that did
me dirty
on my moment but uh we we'll be back in
the building but yo
we're gonna get andrew alliance up in
here you already know the thing is gonna
pull
[Music]
so look i will be back deaf mobile
what's going on man
looks like
anyway look we'll be back we'll get the
rest of the lords up in here
judah said what's up what's up so we be
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i'd be keeping these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting
[Music]
um
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted
[Music]
you could say that i'm very spoiled to
be your dog thing very loyal but i ain't
gonna hold you i ain't here to boil you
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i always been a nerd never been
a loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping and snapple and making it
flammable this is that
fire this is their yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you're just a target when
i'm in the range i was the hardest to
start regardless back when you was
messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by
[Music]
say it i'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't wanna be on the song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start
regardless back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being a
cannibal
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the
[Music]
very spoiled for them to be your dog
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boy you you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you i
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them rings you just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
for you i always been a nerd never been
a loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind
go ahead and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people check my vocals all on twitter
but i'm anti-social love my city but i'm
still by coastal i got it
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
[Music]
them to be your dog thing very loyal but
i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to
boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's sourcing up in the apartment they
call the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
reigns you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them many
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for attic
if i can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee bender i gotta be me
though
i know it's my destiny works incognito
who cares if you fly if you steal a
mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really be stevo
you like to collect and that's cool but
i got bad news
even if you really was that you can't
even still be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible wasn't it
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursued but whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
[Music]
all right and hear ye hear ye and we
are live welcome to the iron lords
podcast
llc and also live on lords of gaming.net
episode number 218 it's another glorious
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's date
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got
dead space remake in ea play
activision blizzard lawsuit and 10 cent
acquiring sumo to discuss
so we gonna get right into it i want to
introduce a lord whose smooth analytical
and informative approach to content
creation
is truly remarkable to watch whether it
be as detailed tech tutorials or
intellectual live streams consisting of
productive advice
all formed with a concise stream of
thought
introducing the created host of the
andrew alliance youtube channel
and the founder of the show radio
the lord of objectivity fellow destiny
brethren
who reminds us all be patient when you
see the vision that the masses
don't live from where
brooklyn at where brooklyn at and making
his debut
into the realm of the lords
my man lord uriah aka andrew alliance
how we doing sir
bro man that was a extremely incredible
uh intro man like i appreciate that
that's that was really really dope took
me back so many different
uh memories and stuff like that you guys
are doing incredible so thank you for
the invitation man i appreciate it no
doubt brother you're a lord at what you
do it's only right we show you the
proper respect here in the realm
we've been building we're talking about
this moment for a minute so it's good to
have you man but uh
first of all how you been what have you
been playing sir
well destiny in and out of destiny i've
been actually on clubhouse a lot
man the last couple of weeks has been uh
you know building some dope
relationships on clubhouse on the
investing side of things um you know
whether stocks are cryptocurrency so
i've been spending time there but
destiny
you know jumping in there you know
uh
[Laughter]
it's like i want to but it's like time
right
yeah time i'm trying i feel like i'm
trying to catch up on on some time
things especially when it comes to like
generational wealth and stuff like that
financial financial literacy and stuff
but you know let's talk gaming gaming
the gaming stuff though is uh destiny
for sure and streets at rh4 i'm actually
waiting for
for turtles i can't wait for turtles to
come out because i'm really excited
about that
shredder's revenge so yeah agreed agree
yeah shout out to oh i believe that's
doterra who did that one and me king
yeah we had a chance to be with the devs
when street rage 4 was first announced
at pax
and we that's probably one of our most
fun videos like
the crew hide everybody we're debuting
the four player
and having a ball and like it's actually
one of our better performing videos
people like
it's a beautiful game man that's it and
definitely congrats on that
it's a beautiful game because um it just
takes us back to
you know the games that we're growing
within the 80s 90s if you grew up in
that era right for sure
um but it's fantastic absolutely man so
we're gonna get into we got a lot to
discuss and you know we already got the
four horsemen of gaming
those original lords of the realm here
at the round table with some uh
time-sensitive intros
because we have that king right yes
i hear nothing he is nothing he
down
i appreciated that though man i
appreciate that changed my life
my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of his own
world
and the how of the young wolf my man
lord addict how we doing sir
doing pretty good uh we got a lot of
things in store for you guys we've got a
great guest and we got some crazy topics
to talk about today
be like there's a lot that happened in a
diameter of one week man
like facts facts and that's that's my
time sensitive topic because
i got to make sure i i leave enough time
to interrupt king on his time
you have to save your ips for kings yeah
yes
anyway and of course we have a most
technical gaming lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience
and also the sastradamus the lord of
clarity and lord patron of the iron bank
mommy lord sovereign how we doing sir
doing pretty good what's going on
brother
i'm chilly i'm back normal to the normal
today uh i'm
actually plugged in so i'm not on
borrowed time probably
not a good remote from the job do i have
to go no the the connection was good
i it was just that you know i forgot my
time battery pack
his
i forgot my power supply and you know
when you have a 2080 in your laptop like
yes
it's gonna die
when you don't get a chance to look into
your fake powerful pc
that's what real power does to
consumption
15 minutes
oh and before we actually start the
topic i do want to
uh talk about uh skyrocketing oh yes
okay yeah anybody been playing sir i
played a little bit of skyward sword
um man oh no it's just i want to get a
stop
i want to give the game another chance
but the thing is
the way they had to translate the motion
controls to regular controls
right still ain't great like it's not
good
better trying
to like to put the sword on a button no
you don't yeah
so besides that besides that i've been
playing this uh 2d
like uh kind of gothic action rpg
well it seems like an action game more
than an rpg it's called ender lilies
yes yes yes yes yes i will i got to plug
the whole room
look out for something from one of our
writers or lords of gaming.net
in reference to that title we were able
to get we got some coverage coming
okay fantastic because the game game is
gorgeous
absolutely beautiful game uh so far in
terms of game play
when it comes to like boss battles i
noticed that it's kind of
deliberate stuff like you really have to
look at patterns and stuff like that but
so
so far i don't have a lot of moves yet
so i don't know how deep the combat goes
okay um but in terms of this like the
stage enemies the regular enemies moving
through stages so far they're kind of
boring and kind of
so but the ball stuff is pretty cool and
like i said the game is gorgeous the
designs are absolutely amazing so
look out for ender lewis um that's
pretty much it
before we transition solved do you want
me to wait wait after we got we
actually missed a couple of super chats
did you get all the ones from the
beginning or any
i only got the very first that was it
okay so lord metro did you get that one
okay yeah that was it yeah okay after
that so we can catch up a little bit
all right so we have omega wolf with the
five dollars but chad
i'm finally able to catch a live show
love the slander and smoke that's thrown
freely
i don't know what you're talking about
sir it doesn't happen
he's familiar if you thought that was
smoke i don't know what to tell you
yeah flame two dollars over jack good
afternoon realm
this week has defeated me flame what's
going on what's that flame
what's going on brother i feel you
brother don't worry monday starts a new
day
yeah [ __ ] with the five dollar super
chat
just wanted to show my favorite podcast
some love wife is in labor now with baby
number two congratulations
congratulations
so i'll catch y'all after lots of love
to my amazing wife
you get that baby shout out to you and
your wife exactly yes please catch us
afterwards if you watch the podcast it
might help her
oh my god but it would engage me
see that sponsorship bro i see you
moving playstation let's go
then we got cedric age five dollars
super chat good day lords good day to
you
sir as well okay hold on let me get i
didn't
get a chance to copy paste these
then we got [ __ ] once again two three
dollar super chat also game pass is the
baby's father
that's great that's crazy guys uh
cedric gave to day loads you read that
one already hold on a second we got
flame once again two dollar super chat
i meant in reference to that news yes
that is very disappointing news
uh you guys know we try to keep it light
here but this
we got to talk about this then we got
paul afc
five pound super chat respect to the
realm i see dead space is a topic you
talk in that empty space in the ps5
mess you can't be with the console
warren
is early it's too early
this is what king has all about
they were caught up king tell them he
paid his good
money to say that exactly oh she shall
be heard sir
respect general back five dollars all
hail
just showing love to the lords thank you
my brother oh hold on slow-mo sent a
super chat i think that is his
so let me get slow-mo afternoon lords
guests and destiny crackheads
hope sounds good right hope you guys had
the chance to play it
no doubt a doubt so we all caught up
yeah we're cutting back my bad slow
money see that's
good good slow is good and of course we
have the incredible hulk of this aka
the access gamer the prophet of
xbox king of the statues if there's
nothing less than that premium
experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir we're
doing incredibly fantastic skyward
swords in the streets
a chance to witness greatness barriers
to the back
man oh so i haven't turned my um
my my nintendo switch on for a while and
when i did turn it on it's like it's my
turn captain
are we in this we got updates and stuff
to do don't worry about it i got you
dude i'll
um we always have this revisionist
thoughts of
games yeah and when we go back to play
them like to me it was always in this hd
resolution but it never was
yeah yeah that's true when you go back
sometimes
or something else you got to respect
any any company that goes back and just
up resident and people think oh that was
a mighty thing they didn't do anything
thank god they did thank you
and they fix a couple of little things
and they it's
for some reason the dialogue is like
faster um
certain people because like before you
have to talk to every last npc
and the way it's structured you don't
have to do that stuff no more um
so of course i'm loving that stuff but
uh
hanging past what's been going on with
the game pass for the week yeah
phil dominus maximus aurelius spencer
wanted to be
as petty as possible and he put out five
new games
okay okay so i'm playing raja is it
is it raj
that game it reminds me of assassin's
creed
uh was it china that one that we were
going from the side scrolling
mm-hmm yeah it's just it's it's
it's crazy it's it's a real good game i
started uh playing that
and my son had me download this game
called curse
fraud like uh curse f r
o d okay and it's like pub g
with powers that's wild
it is literally probably the most
one of the most funky you know i meant
to like pubg but this is like a pub g
was actually fixed like when it first
came out
the foliage is crazy you can you can you
can put cursed things down on the floor
um you can fly into it because i was
like this character like the norse god
and i could fly in and come down with my
hammer and smite people
and it's not it's not something to or
you can run away from you use your power
to run away from people too
but it has a competitive balance it just
really felt like pub g
a little bit more polished with the
powers that we was asking for
and i was just like wow my son found it
and he was like oh you like this and
you know we wind up playing it and then
i wind up playing it with chris and
everybody
and it's it's it was like about battle
royale format you gotta run out for me
yeah free to play battle royale game and
this
everybody's telling me it's pretty old
but it's new to me
so you know it was lit as hell of course
i'm playing outriders you know already
doing carries and stuff like that for
people
but we got our raid in with destiny guys
yeah that's a good raid this week
these dudes hit me up they sold me on
and kyle hit me first first scream hit
me
and then [ __ ]
[Music]
so i get in the room and i come in the
room peeking in like
because i know what they're asking for
that was raised
i had i kept well i would say
will sent me five or six uh invites so
i'm sitting
looking on my screen because i'm
watching uh i'm watching a fun division
and i'm like he don't hit me up unless
i'm trying to do a raid
yeah and i'm like do i really want to
get on destiny because i know
when i jump in the party it's like the
doors get locked behind me i can't leave
oh yeah
we got you we got you so we had we had a
good raid we got it done there was a
little bit too many chefs in the box
but yeah everybody want to be you know
have a voice of reason or something
but it was it was a good rate we
finished the raid of course um
but it's it's always fun gaming
with your brothers yeah it's it's
absolutely incredible that feeling that
you get when
you're in there and you're saying jokes
that everybody knows
and you know it's just it was just we
had some
miscellaneous things yeah yeah it was
called me
outrider dude they tried to act like he
was a casual whenever you mess up
yes but it's you see a different side
attack now
yeah you know he's a father you know
he's a husband and then he has a he has
a different side to him so
it was just so much fun and i was
playing with my guys this week so
i'm trying to get into a couple of more
games before scent hits
this week because i'm going to binge
play that and i wanted to get into
he-man
that just dropped shout out to everybody
that got a chance to see that i hear is
liquid crack so i'm gonna um do that um
you watched that that um what was that
ninjutsu
uh ten skin what was that
yeah yeah yeah yeah i i i saw
probably 10 15 episodes in i don't know
that's my man
did you check out chris tales anybody
check out chris tales no
i have not but people are telling me i'm
about to yeah yeah the name of it says
that's a no for me oh
no no no no no it's a jrpg
that's you know from me oh stop it
anyway
so look oh sorry you want to get that
before i go hold on what did we get
ksanti
five dollars that's door almost made me
miss this show i think i might have a
problem salute to the lords on this
glorious sunday no doubt shout out to
ksi
shout out to him and everybody got a
good channel going on love what they
doing i think it's on the real
i think let me know that k k scientists
will shout you out when the real
yeah right now but anyway and
of course we have the gaming ninja
himself this should no be lord cognito
spreading that realness in a roman iop
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need
to hear shout out to the last word my
boy ibantis thai guy travis youtube
debut y'all we use youtube live for our
first time shout out to e on that
so um yeah we had the amazing zen
martial artist my boy young khan yo
young kong was dropping james king it
was
it was a classic episode he took her
back to the woo tag the run run show off
flicks
kid you got to watch that one with you i
am yeah he he was in his bag so shoot
him to him and then his
story was like a lot of physical
perseverance i don't want to spoil too
much but
he's been through a lot he's been
through a lot for him to be doing what
he's doing salute to him
um yeah we had uh what else i've been
playing uh destiny solstice you know my
grind got that done
um obviously king shout out to raid we
did hilarious rage out everybody out
there messing around scream the crew
said and all that still on my mass
effect two grounds slowly but surely
that and death store i've been uh i got
the death star going on
yeah so salute to that but look we got
to get these super chats again and then
we'll get into i think this hustle
and what else we got hey we just got
hustle two dollars with a chat uncharted
2 is the greatest game of all time
it it's very good sir yeah go give him
that
give him that i mean
is a time and place thing at the time
there was nothing
cinematically like it until the last of
us two came and busted into the
animation
decade later like yeah
when it came out and the leap that it
was over one
like it was it was a big deal it's no
doubt so look
now that we have gotten into what the
lords have been playing we got to focus
on our guest
lord andrew alliance his video what's up
man you already know looking at the
smooth voice
and of course what led him into content
creation on his channel and the
amazing the show radio so laura andrew
let's start from the very beginning what
were some of the first video game
systems you had and what got you into
gaming
well what caught my attention early was
atari 2600 what i
played for the first time was um turbo
graphics 16.
oh king right the floor is yours good
king of your guy
this is your yeah you just spoke
language oh word so we good okay yeah
is an amazing uh system i think you had
the turbo
no my cousin did so i was going all over
to you know
every time i had an opportunity to play
it yeah i'll go to his house
and play it i wonder if he's still have
it or kept it but it's been many years
since removed but
it really inspired me during that time
so that was um
87 so nintendo came out in 85
right so um so i was like okay i need a
system for myself so we went
from um so i went from being inspired by
the turbo graphic 16 playing the games
of that particular platform and just i
just loved the way
that uh the games were designed like
yeah
yeah yeah yeah that was amazing that was
something they stole from sega everybody
yeah yeah but yeah
yeah right right exactly so so just
inspired by that so i was like you know
at the time i was like mom you know i
definitely want to
you know play some of these games um so
nintendo
you know was making a big splash with
all their marketing even then
right during that time so i was like you
know what do i need to do to get it
and she said well if you if you clean
the house consistently for a week yeah
bribery
bribery always works yeah it always
works soft
so so i i just had to do it for a week
solid
you know of course i'll do it after but
that that week i had to be like super
pristine
amazing incredible
white glove in it that was all the
cracks
all that right so um so made it happen
and she got me the uh the nintendo and
that was history since and i know
there's some other consoles there so
between that i went into the sega
genesis okay
okay yeah
yeah somehow i acquired a sega master
system
and it disappeared i never i don't even
know i stopped inviting that dude
whoever you fighting over
yeah i know and then big system
it's interesting you say that because
you know growing up how we grew up
in the city if you spend a lot of time
with cats that come over to your spot
right right so you already know right so
some of the
conscious the cases be good but they're
not right
but there's no game in there right so
and the thing is it's like you believe
and this is a lesson here you believe
that everybody's your friend during that
time
and and from there you're hanging out
with all these people because you have
things in common but just because you
have things in common doesn't
necessarily make them your friend
or they have your best interests at
heart whether that's
industry talk you know if we fast
forward all the way here or go back to
even that air when we're growing up
we didn't know anybody but we thought we
did right yep we thought we had all the
information but i think
of the generation now the the 17 18 19
rules now
they have more data in their hands than
we did back then in fact the early 90s
because of the internet and the mobile
phone and and what that has done for us
right
so so so even then so sega genesis went
through that
and then uh somehow landed on the
dreamcast at some point
sega saturn
we got to give solve some saddle up
because i don't i usually brush past it
for my own blind but
what attracted you to decided we don't
get enough saturn talk
i think that uh the fgc community at the
time
was um the excitement and and the way
that
the community embraced each other you
know no matter where you were from what
you were doing if you understood
you know fighting mechanics and and
cross-ups and
those things right if you understood
that world then you
you had to get like a standard like even
with the king of fighters 94
yeah right around that time you know the
ram cards
yeah yeah and then trying to understand
how to double up on the
the memory or whatever the case was yeah
because you had to put one
one disc and then put the cartridge
behind it or something like that or
whatever you had to you had to you had
to put in the
the first one to be able to play the
import and then you swapped it out for
the ram cart
right exactly exactly so so those things
are like
we we don't get those things um
like we did back then but we see a lot
of companies and to be fair we see a lot
of company coming back
with those kind of things for us to
enjoy those moments that we enjoyed or
you know relive to some degree back in
the day
what i noticed back then um that's when
we started learning about lost frames
and animations
and how those lost frames and those
animations
actually affected gameplay it wasn't the
fact that
you had x-men uh children of the atom
with all the frames inside the saturn's
version with the ram
uh pack to it it was the fact that when
you had the playstation to the untrained
eye you would think
everything is there that affected the
fight
because it's a different fight that
you're having because those frames are
missing and sometimes you're counting
those frames unconsciously
while you're playing somebody so you're
looking for certain animations and
if those animations aren't there it
affects gameplay we learned a lot
yeah from different levels of tech as we
as we grew
through this stuff we learn very facts
uh
small nuances that we appreciate now
yeah but we learned it back you'd be
surprised we really think about the
amount of 60 fps games that we actually
played back then there were a lot
it was a lot yeah yeah yeah definitely
right about that uh king so so even from
that perspective as you look at
um what we have to uh study now when it
comes to even
you know just lean on the ftc stuff for
a second um the things that we have to
study uh the frames and
and how long the punch is out before it
comes back in right
with the cross-ups and the distances
that we have to learn dojo
i'm feeling this right the range is rank
zero one
yeah man even back then we didn't
realize that we were doing homework
to be a better uh you know ken player a
better you know ryu player later on
because it's like this guy just made me
lose like you know five to seven dollars
that i wasn't planning to lose today
thought i was going to be
back do you understand how important
what you just said
we had money on the line money was on
our way it's a whole different game like
these dudes play at home and online i
lost the match yo
when you put your quarter up can you
imagine the line of the guy that's
standing there that's playing and he's
beating everybody and everybody has it
caught up
and he comes to he's eating people like
pac-man and they step
up and he's knocking him out and you're
saying it's my turn i'm going to meet
him
that's right andrew were you were you
did you make your way to the chinatown
fair
and play no i i didn't i was just local
yeah i was i was just local you know
hanging out with my friends i i played a
lot of basketball back in the day but uh
okay
okay so so growing up in brooklyn there
was a um where i was there's a
there's a junction right called the
flatbush and no strength
or was you in atlanta i was i was right
there right there
that's where i grew up i keep that
that's always going to be home i'm not
in that area now because
uh the reason so i'll just uh go over
here and come back to that
um i had a situation recently where
somebody came uh to my home and was
looking through my windows and i just
thought that was strange
so because of that i don't advertise
where i live no smart
place you know so brooklyn is always
going to be home i was there recently at
hamilton's
whatever that is so that that particular
restaurant uh in brooklyn with uh with
my family so i enjoyed that
but um so yeah so so bulletproof roof
comics changed a lot for me
because i was able to go in there and
then just it's just a different
air when you walk in to a place where
you know these are your people right oh
my god because
the frustration of of of losing and
winning
right at the arcade the the pressure
of the money as you were mentioned
before uh king that you know that this
guy was not as nice
and the move that he got you with was
not that impressive
you lost money now you have to go back
four or five in the queue
and now you're watching you're watching
like your your eyes
they don't leave the screen until until
like you look at him over because you
know you get to take them now
because you've done enough homework in
the last four or five matches right yo
let me actually this is the culture
right here i got a chance to witness
actual violence like real
unbelievable violence that that was
absolutely uncalled for but at the
moment
i understood why it happened right so
you remember
when you would sonic boom somebody if
they duck you can just grab them and
toss them
right well this guy was a straight guile
fighter
and we call that cheese don't cheese me
bro
right the one dude he was just kept
doing it and he had this one guy i think
he lost like five dollars to this dude
and he's like yo stop cheesing me bro
it was the last time personal bro yeah
he he did a uh
uh a dragon uppercut and
he was blocking he came down and just
grabbed
him right off the block
he stood up pulled out a knife and
stabbed him yo my god
i told you stop cheesing me bro and i'm
sitting there like
what what do you do what are you doing
i witnessed real violence
it's personal and and i'm not
i'm not surprised because that's that's
an extension
of the person yes yes
because um when when you're not
because losing losing has its place
right you have to lose in order to win
and we all
understand that but the fact of the
matter is is as you're losing if you're
not learning
to be better then you you can't handle
you know the the outcome you can't you
can't handle the outcome
and i think that the the person that
that staffed
is not funny but the person that stabbed
dude or
you know whatever um was an extension of
the fact that he hasn't
he or he i'm assuming it was a he was he
didn't learn how to deal with the
pressure
of the moment right yes it's not it's
not only
of the fact that you're playing with the
person next to you
exactly the fact that you have uh
the magnitude and the amplification of
the noises yes the smirks of the air
like you can like when you're in the
zone like that right it's
when you're in the zone like that it's
like you can't um you can actually
hear people breathing yep when you're in
the zone like that it's yeah
right yeah there's so much yeah you
learn you don't realize it in the moment
right but there's so much you learn and
just in terms of
social skills and and just interacting
with other people and the right things
to do and say
just from that small like that that
small sort of interaction
and you don't realize it when you're
young growing up but i realized that we
had a we had a terror a
panel that i wanted i want to talk about
because this is we're talking about the
mental aspects of this
and representing the competitive aspect
okay i got to cut it just for a little
bit so because
oh no no no no no but i'm going to jump
in with you because i know exactly yeah
you know where i'm going because
this is a chamber that like i said like
if you're not
i feel sorry sometimes for the youth of
today not to be on my old man and back
in our days better bag
but there's a different level of mental
toughness i can assure you
we don't care
there's a different level of mental
toughness that had to be acquired
because
see what what lord andrew lies is
painting this beautiful picture is
you have the competitive aspect of okay
1v1
someone who has a reputation in this
arcade for being great
right then you have the pressure of okay
there are many people around you
including your peers watching to see the
result of this
and your skills are on the line versus
that then there is the
additional mental aspect if you are
dealing with someone
with the tongue and the the the
antagonizing nature of someone who has
could not only fight you
but can talk to you to get you right off
your we call it officially off your
squabble
king is the master of that you know you
know what's funny what uh
i used to play yu-gi-oh competitive yeah
i remember i
i would literally there's like a big
like hidden law like
don't really talk to your opponent oh no
no but it's not against
it's not against the rules so i would
literally have full-blown conversation
because i know
i can keep my soul
and they're talking to me just miss
playing like crazy because they're not
they're not exactly exactly and that
what king was a man not only was he good
he's good at maintaining his focus and
composing
while belittling you right you could be
better in a particular character or
match up and that would take you
completely out of your game and then you
have you have to put it in a box
you have to put it in a box because your
emotions can't be right uh in
in the moment because typically the the
great the wise
the wise individuals in the space
whether that's fgc or
or sports or whatever the case might be
they know how to
uh play uh to your emotions to have you
uh somewhat get your guard down a little
bit right
yeah which is which is why we respect
you know you know kobe bryant and rest
peace michael jordan and
players like that because they're
assassins truly respect
my tutor who's your tutor
the great muhammad ali right okay so
okay so listen i'm a student of boxing
right i knew that these two dudes were
better than me in these particular
things
but what they would do and what i notice
is they get quiet while they play
yes focus focus focus if
i can distract you and then i can do
something that you perceive as
cheap and you feel that
he's not supposed to be doing this yeah
and then and then i take the most
outlandish character
that's not supposed to be working it's
not supposed to be working right because
you should be able to see it a mile away
but if you're distracted by what he's
telling you
and he what he would do he would cheese
he had he he would use
he would use eddie gordon as tiger he'd
use the mask
and put him in half
that you don't want to lose to that man
while he's talking
that talk continues off so he would just
he would just absolutely berate you the
whole
time and in the beginning and i give all
the credit to king for that because
honestly he he made my brother come out
of his shell
yeah he made so many people oh man
he did he really did and and i think
i've said this before
it was all with love right that's your
hair like like it was the thing that if
you were really in trouble
he's the first man there of course of
course he has your back so
but there were some people in our circle
that could not
figure that out and it was always there
was constantly beef between king and
them
because he would again he would employ
these tactics while we played
and they would take it personally and
they wouldn't grow from it
and every week it was week upon week it
was beatings after beatings at the
beatings
because they never got over that hump um
but it was that that was us every single
week
he said week week after week so let's
let's let's just talk about that a
little bit
here's what i mean here's the angle i'm
going to play on on that particular
thing
it's uh the fact that you're waiting
till next week to go back
right and and you're going back to the
proof or you're going back to the arcade
by
king's plaza when they used to be there
right by utica or whatever
uh you're going back to that area and
you know that you've prepared
you've studied you know you've you've
read you've talked to your buddies right
because we can do
like um let's go watch youtube we can do
that we download game facts
right right you did something like that
right
you did something like that right or you
practice
with the people who who were fantastic
in your area
before you went back to the arcade
because that's the only practice that
you would get
and you tell them hey you know don't go
easy with me because i'm about to go
back to the arcade or whatever the case
is right
so i think so the pressure and the
anxiety of waiting and sometimes even
the depression of leaving to to know
that you don't have the money right now
okay to go to go back right so it's like
okay so today i'm i'm done i'm spent
i i came in with 20. i don't have any
more relax and i have to wait all the
way
ready right brett is gone right so i
have to wait till next week to to
prepare
and hopefully i don't lose another 20
next week because i'm better
uh than last week so all those things
man i think as you were saying before
uh lord cognito is is that um the
the individuals that are being raised
today
they don't understand that pressure
preach they don't understand that
pressure and and the uh
the resolve that it takes to to come out
of a situation to be better
oh now now to be fair to them
maybe they do right because if you're
doing a whole bunch of tick tock videos
youtube videos
or a podcast you believe that you're
going to get better some people are
going to say your content is trash or
it's not trash right
so maybe they do so so so maybe i don't
know i'll give this
i'm going to be real with you the whole
thing you'd be talking
only thing like it sounds like to me is
trauma man that's all it sounds like
no trauma problem yeah it is traumatic
it is traumatic it's just a matter of
how you process it like to me is the
arcane has a bunch of
20 early 20 like 20 year olds and
and late 30 year olds in therapy
but it depends on it because but what
therapy though because we didn't we
didn't really look at therapy like we do
today it wasn't
right it wasn't a real thing but if you
had a good buddy or
a good squad back now i actually i'm not
saying back then
i'll get you right right right right
also there's a point we also forget
too that the call out because that
that's another thing that's another
pressure like
people are king you know i'm going with
this where it's like
you know you can be the nicest in your
square or your circle whatever whatever
but the call out was a thing and if you
get called out
from where we were from it was right
there on this one
people drive from other states that knew
of me and
whatever pull up to the house is like yo
we going to 161 rk
right now i want to fight you in da da
da night because to tech i was big in
the tekken scene tekken was my thing
right so you know i was a good horrend
player he was taekwondo artist damn this
this this generated
yeah stalkers too no no it was it was
basically oh it was your name travel
yeah
and it's like you wouldn't it was people
that were good in certain pockets of
good areas and then
as online grew you know people would be
like yo
i know somebody that's really nice and
people would travel
yeah right to fight you like a real like
a real karate flicker yes
it was like it was like street fighter
for real like you know you had to factor
you had to factor in the the traveling
and the cost as well right so it wasn't
close at the arcade you fact but you
have if you had a bus pass
pass right yeah you can't
swing to the bus you can use on the
weekend
if you had if you had that joint you you
made sure you got there oh yeah
connections and stuff like that so so i
i love i love that era
and now we've we've uh transitioned into
from that era
let's listen it's dope man it's dope
there's there's definitely a lot of
lessons there but now we've transitioned
to the online space
yeah now it's it's um the the
reputation now it's not just about the
the money factor because it doesn't
exist you're spending the money up front
to have the equipment to play right
and the internet service to do that
what's at stake now
is um your behavior before
during and after yeah yeah that's what's
at stake now your reputation
right so when we look at the legends and
fgc uh
scene now it's uh what we what we enjoy
now
is their reputation you know with with
uh
that that famous fight with the multiple
blocking um
oh right so so the the reputation of
that will live
on we can't capture uh those moments
that we had back in the arcade in the
90s because
they weren't recorded right correct but
those live on based on the conversations
and
the chats that we have with our friends
and our great friends that's what they
live on but now
we're able to capture those moments and
i think that it's fantastic that we are
at this age so
it's a it's a it's a merger of of the
two
of the two um stages right back then and
now but at the same
time what we we have to appreciate is
the fact that we can have those moments
now because
those equipment to get them into your
home and set up you know a man cave or
whatever cave you set up
is pretty cheap oh yeah these days right
so to set something up like that to have
those moments and even do like a youtube
video and film
those interactions right
it's it this could be that content can
live on be like oh
remember yeah i don't need to
i wish we had the foresight to record
our sessions back in the day
all right right so it's been billions
it's those moments
we have to we have to change those those
moments going man
imagine that mindset playing like how
you guys had playing the haddad fighters
like
back in the day playing like a raid and
destiny like all one room today like
bro it was like i said it was such a
cool era i'm so glad you get up and it's
like you can physically go to that
person that keeps dropping the ball
like what you doing i tell you i'm
surprised that you don't
gravitate towards that attic because you
you have the way you play games
yeah you would to me you would be a
great fighter yeah he would he would
survive in that yeah
crack that is one of the few that i know
was built for that because adam yeah he
lives for competition i think he loves
to be like yo
i'm better than you i'm nice fam so and
that's why i grab
we gravitate towards them because we
from that like it was
it was a competitive era but like you
said all all the pictures you just paid
right you know what i'm saying the
practice the mental game the travel
all the factors the pressure the money
money's on the line
quarters laws you know that kind of
thing and it made you
it developed mental toughness it made
you better it made you
focus you know what i'm saying and i
think that like that's the only thing i
wish more people
had experienced you know saying because
i think that error really
it forged me you know i learned a lot of
lessons life lessons from me
yeah it also brought delusion and here's
what i mean by that
it here's what i mean
because uh the the statement that we
used to say just like the arcade was not
true
talk about it let's go right because we
would see a game
and and we would get the game home oh
yeah
because i have to say shout out to the
playstation
for actually and you know neogeo did it
first
absolutely the playstation did it in the
mainstream manner that it was a
one-to-one
when you got checking in in the house
i'm taking an arcade ridge racing right
and people don't understand why i how i
hold
the playstation in the lofty space that
i
do um and you know people's like what
you hold playstation and lofty space
right now let me explain what the
playstation did
for us what we saw there
on that system board what was the system
i love system eleven system
oh okay and playstation 2 was like
system 21 or something like that
um that system 11 board
changed how the arcades behaved
because now no longer is it uh
graphics different everything's the same
music might be better because of cd
quality
right the arcades had to make the
machines
bigger in order to compete with the
house when you got into daytona you got
into the car
it had to transport you into a world in
the arcade
the playstation made the arcade
a better yeah that's why that it's funny
you
i i know we go along but we're going to
talk about that yesterday i was going to
talk about it yesterday
yeah like that's why i have such an
affection and affinity for playstation 1
because
again like lord andrew was saying is
that
as a kid you're cognizant of that arcade
and when you got home whether it be that
you know you know genesis or whatever
sega master nes
you're like damn that's not the exact
same thing you know i'm saying shout to
paris was in the chat i actually said
that when i was on kind of funny xbox
because i'm a shinobi guy
and that bothered me i'm like yo the
mass system version is not the same like
this is not it like
it's completely different it is not
until generations later as we advance
and technology at home finally was
advanced and then
what sony did was like look that arcade
tech
we're putting that same system board
into
our console so it's a one-to-one
relationship between ridge race and
tekken
all that stuff and you saw it and then
shout out to bandai namco which i have a
huge affection for
they added so much extras also on top of
it so you're like oh man you feel like
you're getting away with it but
contingency this is your history
you're dropping no man well we're just
talking about that
together so you're taking us on this one
yeah absolutely i didn't even realize
what angle that that was going to happen
today because
you always have the idea in your mind of
what you think you're going to be
talking about
yeah and then that that shifts and
change based on the dynamic and energy
of the co-host and stuff like that so i
didn't even realize that
this was going to be the route that i
was going to take but we traveled the
same
roads we walked the same blocks right so
i think it was only fair to actually go
back
uh to the fact that we had some
challenges all of us we had some
challenges
yeah and sometimes those challenges were
trying to figure out how to do a
fireball or how to do an uppercut
we had some challenges what we did right
because when super nintendo
for me when super nintendo came out and
i was playing uh street fighter on super
nintendo
i could not for the life of me
yeah i couldn't do it and our friends
who knew how to do it they yeah they
laughed at us
right they made fun of us we were
bullied
that fireball the fireball and the
dragon punch were two
like two moments for me in my gaming
history where you sort of elevate like
when you can when you can consistently
throw a fireball and
and put out a dragon punch absolutely i
elevated right there it was
it was like another how did you feel
when you got into that dragon ball
battle and you were the fire okay
somebody somebody just just gets nervous
everybody keeps getting closer
and then when he goes to throw his
fireball you throw an uppercut that's it
yeah yeah oh my god
so so that so that's a that's a great
point because um
when we saw that at the arcade
right and you have these two legends in
their own right going back and forth and
just throwing fireballs
and and the the the timing of that like
like i think
i don't think um maybe they do or they
don't the this generation i don't think
they appreciate like
the timing it takes to learn how to play
a fighting game right yeah
so so when when we have and i think
we're spoiled today because
did you say our generation oh no i'm
saying i'm saying just when you think
about
individuals who watch fgc or maybe not
or they don't think um
they don't see why people are so
passionate about smash or any
any game like right it's the timing that
it takes
that's that's the point i'm making here
the timing that it takes to do the
things that
we see or we have the opportunity to
watch or not watch because you have a
live stream of
maybe playstation doing an event over
the weekend i'll be like oh okay that's
another ftc event
but the the the energy
and time that it takes to learn to even
get to like a tournament
yep it's just different it's it's not a
little you know it's not a little thing
and i think that you know
over over time for us even for me
personally for myself you you forget
what it took
for individuals to get to that space to
even compete
right and then you know take a plane or
potentially get sponsored depending on
your demographic if you have the
opportunity
to get sponsored depending on your
demographic right then you get
the the flight you get landed you get a
hotel now
you're ready to go to an event all these
things and i just um
i just appreciate like where we come
from oh yeah oh yeah and we're just
talking about fgc right now
those those those players
are our olympic hopefuls in a way yeah
in in in that whole aspect of it because
i watch these matches these
are trained competitors
is it's something different you you
notice it when you see somebody
have that certain something and it it
takes a stick to it
this a fortitude a resolve within
yourself that you're going to
learn this character to the best of its
ability and it's not
that you can just learn the character in
every move
you are going to know when to apply it
in what situation
and what time and if you can perfect
that little nuance that one little
nuance that you can
break down the range zero range
three where you can break down your its
beauty yeah absolutely to behold in any
game
if anybody can put in that work and
we're at a point now where before we
were told that
video games weren't going to amount to
anything was going to rot your brain
and you would naira
nothing will come from it mm-hmm yeah
but you
would this is a waste of time yep yep
that was
shout out to the 400 plus that is here
we did not waste time at all
and i know everybody here has a
different
tone with their children because
our adults that were you know taking
care of us
didn't see it because they were taught
something different
we saw this we believe this
and we appreciate our rich history
that you're giving us yeah because we
all live it and i know
when we talk to our children we teach
them that freedom and that acceptance
the medium of choice that they choose
shout out shout out to fans he said it
best he said facts king
now it's the biggest form of
entertainment period
so the fruits of that right it's crazy
but look
yeah it's an amazing transition it's
amazing yeah yeah
forgot to transition because i could
talk with this brother for so long or
just
mental gymnastics aspects of fighting
games and things like that
but we got to talk about you a little
bit more in reference to your uh content
creation you know what i'm saying and
you know youtube what kind of inspired
you to kind of like you got a unique mix
you fuse like tech gaming and
entertainment you know what i'm saying
yeah
and i want to talk about that this is
the show radio the amazing
yellow you know absolutely she is
amazing
so let's get to it man like what
inspired you to get into content
creation
well just going back to what we're just
talking about and transitioning it to
now is that i always felt like i was
better at what i did than everybody else
so that goes right into you know uh
creating content for yourself and
and setting up a platform and that
sounds very harsh to some who do not
understand what it takes to
to run um you know any kind of podcast
anything like that
but once you get into the world of
creating content then you realize that
it's not as easy as we make it look
whether that's the lords or anybody else
that you watch
or enjoy that particular content uh so
for me uh it's a it's a combination of a
lot of things
i've always enjoyed my heroes in the
space right uh the podcasters who who've
been
around for a long time who started
before me right
and i think that their inspiration
is incredible because they allow me to
see myself especially if they're them my
demographic right especially there
they allowed me to see something that
i've never seen before and something
that was uh
potentially possible for me but i'd
still
but even with that i still had to do my
own due diligence on
um what i what my voice would be like uh
not necessarily on the mic but just
generate what what i would uh share to
the world right
that would look like right and i think
that so for me that goes back to 2009
but before 2009
um i was listening to a lot of shows
during that time
and uh just trying to formulate do i
want to do
a gaming show or a texture or something
like that well why should i choose right
so you have all these questions that
you're
you're going through to get to a spot to
decide to make a decision so
i actually started a podcast on my
wife's birthday right in august 2009.
so i always remember where i was i was
actually in this room
on the floor and thinking like um
why didn't i just start a podcast and um
a good friend of mine
at the time uh her name is lily we're
talking about different turnkey
solutions
and she said well um you've always
talked about those things anywhere ever
since i knew you because i went to
edward romero
okay okay if you're familiar avenue now
at your shares though
so broadcasting was a bug that was fired
for me
you know i got the bug then because i
was editing in in the broadcasting rooms
of edward
murrow and stuff like that but she said
well just use the turnkey solution if
you can if you don't have
the capital right now and um she said
well block talk radio how about that why
don't you try you know block talk radio
and see you know what you can do with
that particular platform
and um the the whole point of the
podcast in the beginning
was um you know to share things that i
enjoyed
and then it became then there's
different like stages right then it
became
okay now that i'm sharing what i enjoy
let's go
and and try to interview folks who i
loved and admired in the space right
right
and then from from that layer then it
was like okay so now that i've
interviewed guys that um and gals that i
loved in this space
let's go ahead and try to um find a
co-host to collaborate with
right but that didn't come till later so
so you know i tried different co-hosts
in the beginning
um energy you know wasn't right didn't
feel feel right for me
um so i had to um wait until that time
came and
and i'm very i'm i'm very private
but i'm also public i i want to share as
much as i can add value
where i can but i want to make sure that
i'm not always adding the
value of my body right right no i want
to add the value and have the value
stay okay on the internet somewhere so
that people can consume it and hopefully
they find it right and hopefully
it's something that you know blesses
their lives and stuff like that so so
that's kind of like how that started so
so prior to that why i'm passionate
about you know
behavioral sciences and psychology and
things like that is because
um when i was growing up i struggled
with english because
um i went to school in haiti my first
beginning years
and school was in haiti and then i came
in uh i came into america
stayed for for the rest of most of my
scholastic years
but i struggled with english and the
nuances of the language
so i had to take english as a second
language during my middle school days
right
um so that's right uh well
more or less yeah a little bit of french
and crayola and stuff like that yeah
okay yeah a little bit of both yeah i
think
uh creole became a more nationalized
later when i left maybe years later but
french was what they were teaching uh
in school uh in port-au-prince when i
was there um so
so what happened with that was when i
came back and stayed
it was like okay now i'm in this uh
middle school and people are making fun
of me of how i talk yes
right and um it was harsh it was hard
like even looking back and just thinking
about it was harsh but my thing is like
i i gotta get better but when you saw
another haitian
and he said hey yeah that's what that's
always like
of course it made me feel at home and
and what's interesting about that even
some of the relationships i'm building
right now
on clubhouse um they seem to be a lot of
haitians and i love that
you know um because you you it's one
thing for
for for you to be born here but you
have to remember where rich history
are have rich history right yes one
thing that
yeah i'm born here but uh i'm haitian
yes that's just the bottom line right
and i think that
if you go away from that and that's i
know that's a tangent if you go away
from that
it takes so what you're taking away from
everything that your family has done
for you to have the opportunity that you
have to enjoy the things that you enjoy
right so you can't go away from that
so so that's that right so
making fun of me and stuff like that i'm
like i got to get better i got to get
better right
motivation i like that absolutely so so
the way i did that
was watching a lot of sitcoms and um a
lot of
uh soap operas because my grandmother my
grandmother used to have the tv on
look you're gonna arrest us
she was she was such an amazing um
actor right yeah i think that's that's
the proper
uh yeah yeah but
yeah just respectfully i respect you
know that that particular industry for
what they've done
so for me what i was doing is whether it
was um
power rangers thundercats yes all my
children
um a different world who's the boss
any of those shows any of those type of
shows
right um i was family matters i was
watching the nuances of how they
communicated right
yes because if they were great actors
then i would learn something
from their discourse right yes um of
course
um michael j fox and and all those shows
that he did back in the day
so i was spending also when i was not uh
spending time
in the fgc or playing that or playing
crate ball you know you
set up the crate outside you know to
play crate ball and stuff like that
when when i wasn't doing that or or the
fgc stuff
i was i was studying human behavior
right
so 80s 90s and stuff like that so so
what happens with that is you learn to
observe very well so i can kind of
really um i think it's a gift
that that has been trained over time
that i could really read people and
their intentions
very quickly right and that has allowed
me to even speak about the intentions
before
they even yep no role
exactly so so so because of that it
makes you
lonely let's keep it right yeah no facts
because it's it's a it's i got to cut
you for a second because
me you definitely share that and
i enjoy there's a part of me that enjoys
being able to discern the things of
human behavior and the human mind
but the it's the it's the power that's
also the gift of the curse
because when you are able to anticipate
and and see something
like that ahead of time you put yourself
away from situations and then you end up
becoming alone because
you're able to separate from that
negative those negative people that
negative energy very quickly but it's
not necessarily the most
you don't say together existing
situation yeah god calls me the human
lie detective
yeah king has it as well he can like i
literally
can smell the bs and but
it's the environment yeah if you come
from an
environment where you had to read the
temperature of the room
in order to navigate through the room
because all right i grew up in the
projects
um i was big for my age so i had to know
how to
navigate through a room full of
young adults that you're going to find
out if they
are in a happy mood sad mood
what if you got to defend yourself
you're learning
human behavior at a very base level
and how to navigate in a room full of
individuals
and learning what works with this
individual what doesn't work with this
individual and what works with that
and what doesn't work with that but you
have to add a second layer to that
yeah when you had to learn the language
in order to adapt
yeah into an environment that you were
put in
now you you're learning something that
you know english is my native tongue
right and i'm i know that so i just had
to learn how to
move in that room you had to learn how
to
move in that relax and express yourself
in a language that's not your native
tongue and when they heard you
[Music]
kids are cruel brutally cruel especially
that's why
we gotta give them that sure you gotta
give that because we know
look new york public school system i'm
not trying to you know it is what it is
you know what i'm saying and just in
general kids are brutal
and and they they they sense that they
sense that and
anything that appears different or
sounds different
they attack and as a kid that can break
you
so salute to you because at the end of
the day you use that as fuel for
motivation
i didn't know that you were haitian and
you know
like i said i have tons of haitian
friends and stuff like that
but your language
the your verbs articulate and the way
you enunciate
is very english-like yeah it's very
hair-like but your calm demeanor
was trained over a period of time yeah
absolutely and and that training that
train came from from church right
because i grew up
i grew up catholic and i talked about it
um the last 20 years with my pastor
which we
uh had a celebration for his home going
yesterday so rest in peace to him
changed my life i appreciate that man he
changed my life forever and i learned a
lot
uh from him about family and and
tenacity because he was a military
um desert storm desert shield a captain
and brought his whole team back home
and his his only uh prayer was um you
know guy after bringing back home with
my full squad you know i'll serve you
forever and he did
right uh so you see uh people like that
you know he was a big in the stock
exchange world he was uh
executive in stock exchange so so i had
good teaching and even um
in church uh when you're there uh you
see a lot of things
right and um if you're in leadership
then um
a lot of people confide in you right
right
especially if you're a legit you know a
person that can hold secrets because not
every
person can do that but whatever so so so
so that was my training you know that
was my training it was a combination of
um you know i've done uh defense
contractor stuff so i had secret badges
at one point
church training for sure you know
definitely there um and that's going
to be with me forever um but uh also
this industry teaches you a lot of
things yes sir right
a lot of things right and we kind of
touched on it earlier
about um you know character and you know
character assassinations
um character uh assassination attempts
right uh we see a lot of stuff like that
especially when
um your demographic um
has seen a lot of historical uh trauma
and deaths and things of that nature and
now i'm trying to to come up
not just for my crew because it seems
like you guys have been together for a
long time
before the show from what i've gathered
yes right yes
so it's like you're you're trying to
build something with your crew
and then when people look at you guys uh
they automatically think
it's uh it's a fraud because of the
color of your skin right
no yeah no it's really right yeah yeah
and just keeping it real
in the box
until they listen to your content that's
why he's incumbent upon the individual
to bring across
what he's trying what's what's inside i
tell
everyone here just to be them because i
believe in what's inside of them and
each and every last one of us
i believe in what's inside and if you
just show it
right that's why it's very important for
us to be on camera
if you show it
people will know the difference between
faith fake and real
yeah right he got us he got kid got us
out of our show with that
um yeah i mean this is fantastic stuff
man i i would love to keep looking
we could go i'll be bad this is deep
this is we're getting mad we're getting
yeah just let me know when you want to
change uh transition yeah we got three
stuff man yeah what you guys this is a
little bit of a chance a little bit but
i didn't i didn't want to devalue what
was said because
this is extremely important and you know
i love what you're doing again
the journey with like i said tech gaming
entertainment
you know and then i just want to mention
this i just want to mention this right
um
and then and then i'll i'll stop and uh
call you the mic as they say
daniella changed my life for so many
reasons my co-host right
miss cjm definitely uh check her out if
you haven't she changed my life because
as private as i am public um i'm
highly skeptical with people being close
to me right
uh from the hood you guys we can't trust
it you got to earn that right
so when someone is so genuine uh in
their approach to support your content
uh for a while uh to the point that i
end up working with her i've been
working with her since episode 340 we're
almost at 600 now
she changed my outlook on how
um online interactions can translate
into an awesome relationship
right a working relationship so i
definitely want to give her
her flowers because she means a lot to
me i love her i don't i mean i
i love my wife i love a lot of other
people too and i definitely love her for
what she's done
for me and not not just as um as a man
but um
just from a content perspective as well
not relationships absolutely no we got
to give it up to lady daniella that's
that's love what i wanted to say too
before last question before we
transition over to topic stuff
is um you know during your journey in my
opinion like you you've already had some
really cool amazing you know milestones
and
you know the different list of who's who
whether it be content creators
developers you know saying yeah
obviously electric paris lily was in the
chat you know what i'm saying
danny pena i've seen my brother as a
destiny fan
i was very impressed with the uh
professor bro man interview i i really
enjoyed that that was a little too man
no doubt
you even had our sis uh read it for me
yeah ready for me
oh man i love her man i've been
but i wanted to ask you out of all these
experiences all these
different interviews milestones and so
on like
and obviously been on the kind of funny
x cast that was that was a big look too
you know i said
but so i want to say like out of
everything i'll come so far
which accomplishment or milestone means
the most to you
so far so far it's
it's personal growth right because it's
easy to grab something from all those
conversations um and of course you know
shout outs to
paris and red infamy and professor
broome and all the the individuals that
you mentioned
but for me it's personal growth to be
able to be in those conversations
and feel comfortable within myself right
yes and i think that that's
extremely important where i don't feel
like i am leaning in a particular
direction or have a different cadence to
my approach
uh based on the person i'm talking to or
whatever their demographic may be so
so so that to me uh is the ultimate and
where i could take that from the gaming
stuff to
a clubhouse to youtube and you'll still
say
yeah that's a different aspect of what
he's sharing but that's still
him facts yeah right because i don't
share
everything right so so the whole you're
so simple
the whole fgc stuff i knew that that
would be
valuable in this context because we shed
the same roads right
right but it's not valuable to somebody
who's on fgc
so we can build on that conversation
because i knew i was coming
right today right so i think that if
you're still
yourself and still show different
aspects of
of your personality and and journey i
think that's
contextual you have to know the audience
that you're getting ready to talk to but
also
also you have to know when to um not
make things uh very uncomfortable for
that particular audience because they're
not used to listening to that because
you guys have built
something already so me coming to
disrupt that
for the sake of of whatever and i think
that's safe for that
doesn't make sense right right so i
think that being yourself and all this
conversation but shout outs to all the
people that you mentioned because they
changed my life
no doubt no doubt man tremendous man
this is i think you have to read that
super chat yeah the way we
go i don't know because there's some fun
ones for him you want me the last one
first
he he needs to read he needs to read a
lot yeah
so when it comes when it comes to stuff
i say something about that right no
bad guy meaning this is a good thing
this is a beautiful thing right
when we're able to chop it up and just
enjoy each other um
different cultures and stuff like that
so i definitely appreciate that for sure
no doubt that's love that's fantastic
look man we
this is this is this is this premium
contest by the officer and i know people
like we get to the game
but this is this is this is amazing i i
love the way
i love the way you analyze and talk
about things because that's the way i
like to sort of
speak about things and sometimes on the
podcast it's hard because you have
obviously a bunch of different
viewpoints and opinions and things get
loud and a little crazy sometimes and
you don't you never have the time to
have that sort of
quiet moment with a subject and really
talk about it and you
and you bring the soil you bring that
calmness and quietness into it
absolutely yeah like a lot of that stuff
because again sometimes you just need
that good intellectual discussion and
i live for that so it's all good i'm i'm
i'm gonna hold some bias
we coach so anyway oh sorry
but anyway look i just wanted to two
quick questions and we'll wrap up really
move on
um i need the science behind the name
let's get to it
the science behind the name uriah
yeah so um so there's a story and uh
i say story but it's an account uh in
the bible where
um there's a soldier named uriah i just
spelled it different
and uh when david was looking at a lady
of bathsheba to sleep with um
bathsheba was um uriah's
wife right so so with that story
what i really appreciate it is uriah's
character for not
um leaving his soldiers behind on a
battlefield
um to go sleep with his wife because he
sent david
sent him to the front lines correct in
order to die
correct to take his wife to bed his wife
but his wife was steadfast in her
convictions
but keep going i'm sorry yeah yeah yeah
so
so so my whole thing was like so so he
slept with her
and um they had um they had there was a
there was a sea planted in her from
david so david was like yo
uriah go sleep with your wife because
man you know
so it could seem like that was his his
baby right
right right and my my thing was the the
the character that it takes because
everybody always talks about what
happens with
david and bathsheba but they never talk
about
the character and the resolve that it
takes for a man to be like bro
i got my i got my guys out here fighting
and you want me to go home to sleep in
my life that's not even
something i'm thinking about right now
right and i think that his character
i've always appreciated i just felt a
little bit differently
but his character i always appreciate to
aspire to someone where
they say you know you may not like some
of the things that he says or something
that he does
but his character is always consistent
in everything that he does so that's
where they came from
let me let me let me just let me let me
just bring it back real quick
uh rest in peace to your pastor yeah
you um acknowledged his
his journey when he you know prayed to
god to bring back his
people that his his his his team
to get them home safely and i'm just
looking at the parallels
in uriah's
fight where he was that he wasn't going
to leave his guise
because he's not thinking about that
he's thinking about his men on the
battlefield
absolutely and then the name comes from
that genesis and it's just
the parallels in the two did you think
at that point in time that
you were given a tribute to your pastor
when you did this
i did not did not and now thank you for
for bringing that together
i did not yeah because i just look at it
and i see how
the adulation that you have for this man
how the man impacted your life
and you took that cause and that that
that that same sort of story close to it
or whatever
but it just it just forms you like we
don't know the things that form us
around us and we don't see it and
we do things subconsciously but
subconsciously
you use that name as a tribute to the
man that impacted you the most
wow yeah that's amazing thank you for
that man i
i never connected those dogs i
appreciate that the king is always
driving knowledge um yeah man look
fantastic history
love the journey gotta ask you the
question we asked all the guests in the
realm
this is these are two big ones right now
i need lord andrew alliance's top
five video games or franchises
of all time i have no idea where this is
gonna go
i'm curious top five yeah so video games
are franchise these are the most
important to you
personally to me personally
okay all right we gotta throw mario in
there
yeah no doubt we have to because that
started everything for me
we have to throw um
halo in there oh okay let's go
for sure for sure reverse we got a
platform
we have to throw halo in there let's go
i mean top five is tough right
top five is tough so so we have mario we
have hair but we have to do
sonic in there because that changed my
life first sonic i got
sonic in a bit that's what's up oh sonic
you know they they're getting ready to
make another sonic game soon or
something like that i'm excited about
that i love something yeah
sonic mania was just playing that
recently so sonic is definitely good no
doubt
wow um this is tough
but um i know there's some allegations
with stuff going on right now but i
gotta throw in
uh bungie and everything they've done oh
yeah yeah come on now right
um especially with destiny
welcome talk here okay
act like yeah
yeah so this is the last one so so
whether i'm actively playing it or not
is is not necessarily like how i'm i'm
deciding right
but i definitely have to throw in call
of duty because i changed some real talk
right real quick so yeah so i think that
that's a safe five i mean that five can
change
when you come right over there other
ones right but uh of course uh you know
um
gotta mention uncharted because that's
legendary
they they could be in the top five as
well but it's tough right because
it's really uh the top five is connected
to my journey um
for for gaming so sonic had to be in
there mario had to be in there of course
hill had to be in there at least those
three had to be here
the other two whatever but those three
juggling
whatever dude and make it tough now yeah
pick
from your kids favorite console of all
time
generation and why
wow um man you guys these are tough
questions
because because you have memories with
so many of them right and you just have
to
okay so we talked about nintendo and
stuff like that but i think i'm gonna
i'm gonna give this one to
genesis because i remember i remember
when i was um
you know growing up and i would go up
the escalator and macy's
and then her rise from your grave i
would i would look over
right and they'll have all these screens
and then sonic would be running on all
these screens and i would just remember
one day i'm gonna have this console oh
my god
nice and and every time you know i'll go
shopping with my mom
i didn't like going shopping with my mom
but you know she
that was her thing her and her sister
right but i would i would tag along
but every time i would go up the
escalator and see sonic running on the
screen genesis does
you can't do this
that's when the company
exactly so i'll i'll say sega genesis
because i mean
we can pick a lot of different colors so
i'll stay with bigger chances
yeah this is definitely blast master
process
tremendous game history tremendous look
man we can talk to you
all day man yeah man we got to do it
again
we will be linking up for sure even more
so i love these conversations we got a
show to do otherwise people
can start yelling at me let's get it
up you get last week's poll real quick
last week's pro results are in and the
people have spoken
with the recent information and spec
reveal of the portable steep deck by
valve
will this affect your purchase of the
nintendo switch
oled the winner at a dominant 78
of the vote was yes steam deck
is the switch pro we always wanted more
powerful more features and versatile os
for games
coming in at second place was no switch
still
has exclusive first party games and is
in a completely different market than
the steam deck
and in the last place was the messi
lloyds it's all fun and games until all
those 720p
pc titles destroy that hard drive group
shout out to all the lords
who participate in the uh lord solved
look like the steam deck gang is uh
victorious uh your thoughts sir
listen man i told y'all i was coerced
into having to purchase an
uh switch oled my nephew does not call
me for anything
he made sure that i got that phone call
letting me know that hey that oled is
announced
so come october 8th i'm going to have
your old switch right i'm like
yeah i i guess so like
what am i going to tell the child no so
yeah i'm getting a switch over that yeah
get that switch we'll see how that goes
we'll see how that
how that generational leap feels
no no dealt so look man we got some good
topics some good
show i think i don't know if attic is
back but we gotta get into this all
right you wanna get these super chats oh
yeah yeah yeah let's get the super chats
get super chatty while we're gonna go
away from that's true good point
okay okay so hold on a second
i'm gonna run back a little bit we got
omega wolf with the one dollar super
chat thank you so much then we have a
mega bull
again with the five dollar super chat
was huge into magic the gathering
growing up and my favorite deck was
went missing i thought i lost it my mom
gave it to a friend's five-year-old son
oh wow yeah then we have kate smith ten
dollars to be chat
thank you lord addict for playing
death's door on the on youtube because
you have now convinced me a person who
does not play any games that are not in
game fast
to buy this game and keep up the good
work so thank you so much yeah you see
absolutely people got people purchasing
games on xbox how could that be
so we got rezzy mobile five dollar super
chat peace to the lords on the lord's
day
man this competitive talk has put me in
a time machine
you had to have a tough mind and thick
skin back then that's what you did
yes no doubt no doubt was that one bad
mother that pulled up off guys
i see you no no
then we have d rob five dollar super
chat getting an arcade machine at the
firehouse
engine 293 pull up oh is that a
challenge that sounds like a challenge
yeah you got to go the way you want to
fight
then we got the family 108 dragons tv
five dollar super chat
shout out to the fam i'm only here for
the king and hip hop rematch
let's go in my dog king voice
popiniquity of
then we have fonzarelli gaming ten
dollar super chat the show may go long
but the lawyers can talk about anything
old or new and make it relevant and very
entertaining
the conversations are free-flowing and
real no other gaming podcast is as great
as the ilp
thank you my brother thank you so much
love much love
uh then we have gamer by choice twenty
dollars to be chat salute to the realm
on the lord's day for great
conversations and an amazing guest
this is why i do not miss an episode so
far
hit the like button people thank you so
much appreciate it thank you
then we got scrub nurse five dollars
super chat y'all hit my heart with the
real talk on life and gaming keep up the
great work salute to the lords and the
chat
crest up no doubt thank you then we got
gerald
mack five dollar super chat all hail the
iop these brothers got crazy reigns
shout out to the lord
then we got tony bryant five dollar
super chat this show definitely for the
culture iop
always spotlighting creators i did not
know i needed to listen to or watch
that's the plan that's always been the
plan yes
and i think we're caught up no doubt is
that lord
one bad mother writer for xbox era and
podcaster on on the uh basement radio
arcade pocket is that him
is that the legend
he's not talking about he seems like he
can hear you
but i can't i can't he's not talking
back mother talk to us
you're smiling you're not talking
getting here i don't know what's going
on maybe maybe he can't hear
maybe he can't hear us all right how has
he went this long thinking we're talking
to him
oh he's muted he's muted he's talking
but he's muted yeah he's beauty okay
he can hear cuz he's smiling all right
let's see he's figuring it out he's
figuring it out it's funny because i'm
looking at him his lips aren't moving
yeah i see i see what he's connected
away just make sure and so just make
sure
you pick your correct uh microphone
device it might it might have defaulted
to something else
i've had it happen before so don't you
worry about it it's all good
you know what i'm saying but once you
got it nope still don't hear yet
you you just keep talking to keep
switching
you have to you have to pull up the app
to go inside of it to switch it to your
mic
because it went to default it probably
defaulted to another audio setting it's
fine
tony tony bryant saying cog with the
fake surprise
there he is testing
testing you are in the building one bad
mother
legendary the writer of xbox era and as
well on the uh basement arcade radio
podcast oh man brad how you doing man
ah man i am awesome especially now that
i finally made it in here uh
cogs thank you long overdue i know
thank you so much for having me and uh
yeah hopefully i'm leveled up
uh better than i was when i joined you
in the destiny right yeah oh yeah oh
yeah
yeah you crashed already i forgot about
but look man we got some
some good topics to talk about so i want
to get this to add this is his topic
um what's going on man a little ea play
and then a certain game you were excited
about right sister
yes it seems like um it seems like
they're getting their stuff together man
like
obviously we have to see how ea handles
things going forward but
i think our man over there vince man i
think he's changed the the
the flow of how ea does things because
first
he was able to convince them to do their
own star wars that wasn't a a micro
transaction
and now it looks like out of nowhere
dead space is returning
so you know what i want to ask is first
off i don't know who here's played dead
space who here has not played dead space
and if you have played dead space you
know with this remake coming in what is
something that you want in dead space
the remake of what's something that you
prefer them to keep away
from this game no doubt let's start with
uh let's start with uh lord israel lions
are you a dead space
guy or not or where you at with that
space
is that exploding babies
is that the game holding babies yeah
exploding babies if if that's the game
that explodes babies i don't really do
horror
i appreciate when when refreshes come
and still
honor uh the game that was originally
released right so i think that's
that's how i i do the framework on that
um nothing
in specifics i like watching games that
don't play
so that's definitely going to be a game
i'm going to be uh watching individuals
who stream it
but i i'm excited for the announcement
for those
that i know that play games like that so
that's where i stand on that i yield
no doubt no doubt let's get uh lord one
bad brother man are you a dead space guy
did you watch it
where are you at with this whole thing
with ea play no actually
it it's interesting that the years that
dead space came out and were really
popular were the
the few years i took a break from gaming
uh you know i told you i took
i told you before cog that i experienced
mass effect two and three for the first
time just a few weeks ago wow
you know so uh by the way that yeah that
made the top five pretty quick
absolutely
but some of this stuff has been really
exciting you know i i going to backwards
compatibility has been a big deal for me
to make up for those three four years
where i was you know i had to step away
from gaming to get things back together
uh but you know dead space has been one
of those things that it's been sort of
at the the
forefront of the you know up next games
for a while
but i've been been hoping waiting for
some you know sort of remaster
like what we had with the mass effect
and so this is something that i'm
actually pretty excited about and
you know i you know just like attic was
saying the thing that's exciting about
you know what we saw with the ea play
and i went in not expecting much
uh although you know we we had heard a
lot about the dead space but
it it does seem like ea is
taking some feedback or you know maybe
just some pressure on the brand
and and starting with the mass effect
and now this at least it's trending
in the right direction so hopefully you
know we can keep the pressure on them
with this but
i think there's some good potential with
this especially you know
considering what type of game that is
there's probably a lot of potential
for this to be a lighting showcase you
know kind of like we saw doom three
some years back right so so yeah i think
a lot of good potential
uh i feel like feeling good about the
direction from that show
no doubt no doubt let's get uh lord sob
man that you're dead space guy they
don't ever do this
dead space is the goat survival horror
game
thank god because i thought i was going
to do this whole thing for a second
i was like everyone's dead
um it took all the lessons that
that res evil put out there um and sort
of you know
obviously being the first to kind of do
something you're going to be stumbles
and dead space took all of that and
improved upon it to the point where if
you play that game today
there isn't a lot in terms of quality of
life stuff that it still
needs like it really needs like it
really plays well when it holds up very
well
to be honest with you it really is it
did a lot of things in terms of ui
um minimalistic ui where everything can
be seen
on your on the player character um and
in terms of atmosphere
uh lighting things like that uh jump
scares that made
sense um and just an overall sense of
tension
and and and and dread throughout the
entire game that i don't think a lot of
games even today have been
able to sort of broach
it is a special game and the second one
i think in a lot of ways even more so
even though it's a little more action
oriented
um so to see it come back
is is really exciting because from what
i've read so far about what the devs are
talking about
the original dead space was limited by
the hardware of the time
right there were things in terms of
design choices that they had to sort of
cut back on because the hardware
wouldn't allow for it
where they're looking at that and saying
okay like like andrew said how do you
take
the old thing and bring it forward in a
way that still
uh has reverence for for for the
original game
and the the devs now are doing that
where it's like all right we're gonna
try to take what their original vision
was
and now we have the hardware to be able
to bring that vision to life
in a way that makes sense while still
creating something new out of it
so i'm excited to see it i'm glad
they're bringing it back like
like attic said i think we said this as
soon as vince sampela sort of got
ascended uh over there at ea yeah he got
ascended at ea that things were gonna
change
and um
you can see it this this kind of moving
away from
the idea that they have to monetize
everything and that they
you know they they have to find some way
to each every dollar out of every single
property
instead of just making good solid games
um
so i'm excited for this i love dead
space
they if the if you could make a remake
of the goat
and have it even touch a little bit of
that magic that the first one had
you're going to have a lot of people
excited so yes that's basically let me
ask
both of you hardcore that face faces
guys
are you guys concerned that it's not
just going to be like a
remastered as a rebecca like are you
concerned about any integrity of the
game
you know thomas being that you guys love
it so much you know what i'm saying that
oh yeah i'm curious about that for y'all
ah i mean yeah
go ahead i watched the little extra
stuff where the devs were talking about
like
yeah it kind of seems like when i see
what they're doing it feels like
a more of a what uh
what capcom does resident evil it feels
like we want to keep the game more
quarter and it's like the little stuff
like
the the g g-space stuff where like
you're floating around they want to
improve stuff like that
because but as far as like the
environment
they want to keep all that natural and
they want to keep it how it was back
then
yeah so i think in that regard i think
alex wright i think they
they're looking they looked at you know
re remake two
re2 remake um and said okay
how do we keep the core of this where
the fan base will not be
appalled at what we give them and still
make because i will speak out fresh
yeah but you know me i i'm you know me
i'm the dude that's not afraid to blow
the thing up so blow it up
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah okay yeah you
went you would add a diametrically
opposed
to that that is a big difference between
you two because king i mean it's king
saul is all about
do something new and addictive not like
that if it's his core
franchise yeah if it's something he
loves leave my stuff alone it's gonna be
a very big chance to see how this is
handled because that's what you guys
the thing is is like like i don't mind
when people do it
and it makes sense but sometimes people
will remake stuff
and nothing makes sense why they did it
it's like they went for a new
uh a new demographic of people they
missed it no one none of them care
now we don't care so now you got to this
point where
no one cares about your game and that's
the thing i think re2
got it perfect where the people that
cared about old re2
were in love with this and new people
were like wait a minute what is this
this new 2d
action game so you have to find that
balance and that's going to be difficult
but
i think they have people who care about
this property
in charge so i'm confident no doubt no
doubt
are you re 2 and final fantasy 7 remake
they did something i didn't think was
possible they
they they pretty much had like when
someone red
does a quote-unquote remake people was
like is it really a remake though
like is is it like is it technically a
remaster
like i don't see it being a remake like
like now now there's like
kind of like another like another little
line it's okay so this is
it's like they take the remake and they
cut it in half okay over here it's like
a remake
left where it's like final fantasy vii
it's like here's a remake right where
it's resident evil it's technically the
same thing but it's not the same thing
like
yeah it's got interesting yeah one last
quick thought on that i've
kept on that so from a non-fan
respectfully you know
what what what the franchise is say
respectfully man
we beat it effectively
so there was something beautiful about
the trailer uh when they
showed the character and i would say exo
suit the exosuit lit up
one at a time i just felt like that was
something iconic to be excited about
even 100 not even a fan so can you guys
talk about that a little bit like how it
is in
uh dead space is those lights on his
back
there's a different uh color for like
right there's red
it's this health bar yeah it's his
health bar so like the more damage he
takes the lower that health bar gets
yeah so like i said before
everything ui wise is is portrayed
organically on the screen
you don't ever really go off to a like
you don't press
like start to pause and go into like an
item screen and start doing everything
happens
organically kind of kind of in the vein
of what what god of war did where
everything is a kind of a single shot
this isn't exactly that but it was sort
of the first to try to
100 keep you immersed in the world at
all times
and that to me is what sustains that
feeling of dread throughout because you
never really feel
like you're out of it king i don't know
if you remember right so essentially
lord uh sovereign so the tension is
never released in the game as you're
playing
it never really is king i i don't know
if you guys played this i know king has
played it you remember
zombie u mm-hmm the launch title for the
zombie u was another one where it's like
when you your backpack
was was assigned to the to your little
uh tablet right
and the thing is to get supplies out of
their backpack you had to
put it down go into the backpack that
was all real time
so if you had zombies coming your way
you had to do that
quickly in real time yeah and then
it asked for the tension in the sense of
dread so then when it went to the
playstation and lost that
yes when it went everywhere else in los
angeles
really because a tablet was that game
was designed around
yeah the only thing that i felt like
dead space dead space did i i
feel like dead space is almost a perfect
horror game like it really is and that
guy's got too much hyperbole
but it is what it is when it comes to
certain scenarios like they definitely
could have done better
but it's like like i can't think of
another horror game and i've played a
few of them
that that capture is because it's about
immersion
yeah when you play dead space it
sometimes people throw you know jump
scares and stuff at you
mm-hmm but when dead space does it
you're dead if you don't do it right
ain't no hyperbole where's bg where's bg
we gotta get the kid cause he clearly
has a different opinion
let me go before i'm sorry because he he
he he going
to you go last no no no
last time i checked uh cognito when it's
his topic and i asked to go first he
says he wants
to do it
open you open the topic and then you
also close the card
oh my god i open the topic
okay what you do what you do i ain't
doing what i do i like call choose the
order
go ahead add it go ahead look
i i'm glad that they're doing this uh i
i hope that they
improve certain aspects of it um for the
most part
i don't think they need to really change
much in the combat just make it a little
bit more fluid because
the good thing about this combat is like
it always made sense
it's like they they go to they fight
these creatures that no one's ever seen
and the thing that helps them the most
is is a mining tool
yeah you're an engineer so like you're
using these these
these mining tools and stuff and and you
know you're just
i don't back then i don't remember games
that was like you're cutting legs off
and stuff like to the degree that game
was doing it like
you could literally cut their legs off
and they'll start crawling
to you late and then and then not to
mention like dead space is one of the
very few games i've seen
that they they had a whole department
making death scenes
yeah like literally you could there's
like i think there's like 150 different
ways to die
in in dead space so you know i really
like the
you know the fine detail they're going
to make on this i think that
you know dead space brought back
correctly is going to take off
i think it's going to have a pretty
decent following now obviously
it's still a horror game and i don't
think the overall demographic for horror
games is is huge
but i do think if you really want to
bring that
genre back in a big way dead space is
your
your your king is just so disrespectful
oh what is that wait why is he laughing
like that what's going on right now
you want to bring survival horror back
i don't know what's happening right now
if you have truly done your thing
already y'all have
really beat the horse to death and okay
first of all the goat is residue okay
okay
this is what this is about we're not
going to act like resident evil is not
the undisputed heavyweight champion when
it comes to survival horror
no matter what twist and turns that they
went they
also came back and recaptured their
crown and said
sit down now in that space
we're talking about survival horror now
i'm going to give you this i'm going to
give you in
space horror mm-hmm dead space
is the pinnacle all right so you're
giving respect okay
but the way he was acting like i'm
taking away the hyperbole
from the situation because you know why
because it seems like you've forgotten
what survival horror
oh no no how can how can i help
what i'm saying if you're pointing if
you're pointing to
the remake hold up if you're pointing to
the remakes
if you're pointing to seven and if
you're pointing to eight those lean more
into action we're not talking about that
though
i love resident evil
and interrupt the last little bit of my
head
stop acting like you didn't interrupt
him because that's lying
but you the king in the interrupt per
second no i'm just saying
listen i'm happy to have you talk but
when you come back with a with a
whack i'm not letting that right first
first why is it whack
though you know why i thought
i don't know what i'm saying he came out
no no no
you're finishing it all i'm saying god
came out you came out and said
that that residual came back came back
took that crown
back right yeah resonate with you which
is fair
right now no it's still more of an
action game i don't care
did you not finish that game did you not
finish that game with mad ammo
hold on how much ammo did you have when
you finished that game
has to step out on the battlefield first
so we're going to take the pack against
the past listen and i would sit here and
eat crow if that remake comes out
and i finish that game with 500 rounds
of ammo i'm gonna eat crow
i will yeah so so check it out good kick
you're never going to take you're
never going to take resident evil's
level of tension when you turn around
that corner
and you fee you see that first zombie
but you popping this noodle off you're
talking about
oh um this is the first time i've seen
the limbs come off here because you can
aim at lens you got a chance to see the
goat go first
and you're gonna come behind and spit
wait a minute
is
so you can stop with your hyperbola
so you know you have alien isolation and
stuff like that that tried to mimic that
type of space horror type feel but they
never can quite
get to where dead space went
and it was that g space the first time
you went into the g space and your boots
you know because when you when you walk
on solid right you feel
the gravitas of the character he's an
everyday man
he's just an engineer he's not no marine
he does not know this he's not know that
he is an engineer okay all right so they
put you in that and he's using engineer
tools to fight monsters that are
inhuman one hit decapitations
you know um you really have to play the
game
as a psychological fear driven game
now you approach every room differently
you don't approach every room the same
and i'm going to give you what it did in
its space
it's just a hyperbole of it it's i just
can't go with that part because it's a
greater game
then you also have silent hill
which is a survival horror game so
and and that is a different aspect of
survival horror right so when you say
and
maybe for you this is the goal for me
the goat will always be resident evil
okay it will never take away from what
me you
barry and everybody sitting in the room
quiet as church mouse
when it's your turn to get on that
controller and your heart is pounding
out your chest when them dogs bust
through the window
but it's like you got a point there but
this is the thing though right we've had
this argument on
on for a number of games right we talked
about the mass effect one versus mass
effect 2 thing right when you
have when you have hindsight right when
you have hindsight
to me dead space took i i said it when i
talked about it
dead space takes all the learnings from
res evil yeah and it perfected it
correct so why can't it be better and
not spit but it's better after you get a
chance to hear the best
so you can you can little things it
improved upon the things that needed to
be improved upon
you see what you're not looking at what
resident evil did
it spawned survival horror
it made that joke so how you can not say
that's the goat
like because it's me because it's first
doesn't mean is
let me ask you a question king okay you
seem to be
really really enjoying the resident evil
franchise okay
yes sir what what was some of the
enhancements that they made in resident
evil 2 that
that made you feel like they brought
that up forward
visually they told a story from a
different perspective that you didn't
have that
information and the first time you
played that game
yeah i get that so so that whole
crash and stuff like that that you got
to raccoon city
it was smashed up but you didn't know so
let me get to that let me ask you
so you're a huge fan of resident evil
right no i'm a huge fan of giving
respect to games
and that that paved the way oh this
feels like a subtle thing but
it feels like it feels like you can't
try to set me up but trust me
oh no it's already
you're giving so much props to resident
evil and that they're the go
of this of this horror thing but you
didn't even beat resident evil 2 remake
if resident evil doesn't hit your game
don't exist
well i mean clearly
look at your mouth
don't look at my timeline look at yours
maximus are really expensive
in the chat you know you know he took an
l on this list
you know when they got a panda for l's
they lost
brandon you know that a panda for help
so listen my rationality this is
i'm not taking away from your love of
the game
actually i'm giving you tribute for what
it did
it fixed a lot of things like movement
and control
first we had the biggest problem with
resident evil was the control of the
character they took away the tank
movement
right so this is where your affinity for
this game happens because you
hated that tank movement you said why
are they sticking to this arcade
movement i remember you i'm watching you
i'm here
so i'm present so at the same time i
know you said the quality of life you
see the little light bars on the back
and
you see when he pulls up his it was all
revolutionary fun stuff that they did
beautiful put it in his reverence
right so so so let's say this right
after
let's say this let's say this one second
i have to lord hogue has entered the
world
i just got to make sure his levels are
good and he can hear us bloviating
my levels are always good right yes sir
the virtual galleries are the critical
difficulties there for folks who got to
see me pop in and out i think
i just i just real quick solve i'll let
you continue it then we gotta get huge
take so so let's
let's say this let's say this in much
the same way
that i'm going to charge uncharted yeah
of course i know you are
that in much the same way the uncharted
learn from tomb raider and intermediary
came back and learned from uncharted i
think this is the same thing
right where you take the originator
which was the goat for a long time i see
this i see where you going still the
goat
no they originated i'm talking about
that he's talking about it okay
i'm talking about resident evil but the
difference is i played resident evil 2
remake so he's invalidated continue
three i got part three i will give
king that resident evil 2 as a whole is
better than the dead space franchise
but i'm not saying that the resident
evil franchise is better than the dead
space franchise
because to me the only good ones they've
really made is resident evil two and
four that's all that's your world right
oh no no i don't i don't agree i don't
know every day
but at the end of the day all i'm saying
is i could give you resident evil 2 but
you can't give me anything
dead spaces i feel like it's better
than the rest of you know what i said
god bless i respect your choice
respectfully i mean obviously all i'm
saying
yeah i gotta understand that both of
these franchises were dead at one point
if mines wasn't alive
and talk about oh the pinnacle of like
wow
this is the greatest thing some
schweinsteiger you know
like i said is that that is that me1a2
argument i don't care which way you're
saying the thing
i'm gonna tell you it's the same thing
no resident
very long and i got let's get let's end
it with king said i just like rezzy
we're better
that's it oh
lord hold up real quickly before we
transition i
did want to get your input on this um in
reference to dead space
oh i don't know if you're a fan of dead
space the ea we see ea play
what are your thoughts about what was
seen or just the franchise in general
oh well you know i i think dead space
was a perfectly nice
video game franchise that was put out
there by ea when they were desperate to
get
some attention back to their brand when
people were really upset at them
and they pretty much immediately
crippled the company that made it
uh and are now retooling it with the
company that made half a game that i
didn't really
like but that's me being cynical and mad
i like dead space just fine i don't know
that it needed a remaster or
you know when i look at articles that
say things like we're improving the
story
i say well okay i've been down that road
before with
properties so right i'm interested to
see where that goes but
i i'm a resident evil guy pretty much i
think we're talking about that
so you know one the question is talk did
you beat residents
why you gotta pull receipts on hold come
on wait what
what did you beat resident evil 2 remake
home
did i beat it yes did you play and beat
it oh yeah no i be
yeah i played the resident evil 2 remake
why okay i'm just happy
because king was capping for it he
didn't beat it
philly eagle in the chat says resident
evil 6 is greater than wrestling with
two oh my god
continue hold continue
crater has different definitions no i i
like dead space just fine i think the
first one
especially stands out um i don't i don't
remember
much of two or three there was a third
one right right yeah
oh yeah so
though you know i i want it to be good
um
but i i'm holding out for a while if you
read those articles i think it seems
like it's very very far out it seems to
be electronic arts
yeah uh pressing for content so we'll
see how it looks i want it to be great i
want everything to be great
no doubt i'll jump in real quick i did
not realize the debate was going to
break out today
regarding resident evil and destiny this
definitely didn't see coming so
apologies you said it expect this to go
this long but look
um you know i'm obviously new to this uh
franchise i want to shout out my uh
defining
co-host mr baddie plays um he is
hardcore for this game like he is like
cog
you've got to play it he's he's in the
solving attic bag and he's like
look this is the goat you know he he's
very
so but his thing actually he made a a an
interesting point which was
he said don't wait he said still
play the original and i'm like yeah but
the 30 frames though
he was like look he's his concern is
kind of what holger lee alluded to
in reference to i guess uh visceral
games which was a disbanded or broken up
and
you know in reference to the original
right yeah so that that was a big deal
and now
you know to ea motives defense from what
i hear they are consulting
uh some dance from visceral to try to
get that feel try to get that essence
that's big um i do like the fact it's
next-gen only andrew alliance you know
so
for me that's something that piques my
interest to see you know them push the
hard way forward
cool teaser no release date just yet you
know um
i'm just gonna wait and see i i love the
passion that attic has for it you know
he
he it takes a lot to really impress him
in that level
and uh one bad mother i think we gonna
be rocking that day man when it comes
out
i gotta give it a shot just cause this
debate is so spicy and people are so
compassionate
about it now i have to play this game it
seems like nobody got cut in the process
[Laughter]
but look man we gotta move on wait till
the next resident evil comes out man can
you play it
can you play it he got receipts ready i
would buy it and i would sit there and
look at it
look at me i gotta move on together we
gotta respect people's time here but we
got
the legendary lord virtual legality
himself hoga
and um this was a very you know
really spicy topic this week you know
this is a lot going on
you know obviously we've seen the state
of california
versus activation activation blizzard
serious charges here
serious charges here so um i don't want
to fraud like i
knew every aspect of the legal process
here so i wanted to get whole game but i
had
had some questions before hogman i mean
basically yeah you know
we've seen the lawsuit we've seen
allegations some of these things are
extremely
difficult to read yeah and um you know
you you ha
i watch a virtual gallery amazing
virtual gallery by the way
and um you know you had some points and
the first point
i wanted to kind of get is obviously
there were the charges made
right and you had two points one was in
reference to the state of california
and how you were concerned with some
aspects of the complaint
right and the way the way they kind of
yeah yeah
the way they kind of frame certain
things and then the second part was
obviously
um activision blizzard's responsibility
to ign
and in reference to the comments right
so let's start with the first two like
do you think you know the way
it was posed could there be any issues
for them as far as trying to win this
case
let's start with uh of the actual state
of california
yeah i mean let's let's start out with a
couple of things right because i think
there's a lot of
places to have foot faults and for
people to get
um invested in in one aspect of the
story or another so for those of you
that didn't
watch my video it's an hour 20 minutes
long totally understand that
i put out a couple of disclaimers one i
i'm a lawyer i'm not a california lawyer
california's a special place even in the
united states they do a number of
different things than other
jurisdictions one of those
is that they invest one of their civil
institutions the department of fair
employment and housing
uh with the ability and indeed the
mandate to go and investigate and
litigate
against companies operating within
california so you don't see this
kind of lawsuit and behavior in every
jurisdiction you might see something
brought by the attorney general when
something looks really bad
but this is actually a state of
california action that is
brought based on complaints that were
raised to them as it turns out from the
document that they've presented
sometime in 2018 if not earlier um so
they collect complaints just like if you
had a problem
in whatever state you might be living in
and you complain to whatever your safety
bureau might be
your osha equivalent in whatever state
you're operating in and they might
investigate a complaint and then they
might turn it over to the ag here
the agency actually sues itself and when
the agency sues what they do in this
complaint is they say we're suing on
behalf of us
as california to say california doesn't
want harassment doesn't want
discrimination all stuff that makes
sense
right and they're also suing on behalf
of what they
classify as every aggrieved woman
at activision which if you followed
anything on class actions or anything
like that is a very broad class
but the history of california has been
that they have been permitted
and authorized to get away with
describing broad classes for a while
at least through discovery until they
can be challenged by defendant and so
what you've got is
you've got a lawsuit that reads to most
people
as if it were a civil class action right
that it's a state action but people get
caught up
why aren't people going to jail it's not
they don't have the right to put people
in jail
that's the justice attorney general in
california this is about
fines and penalties and other things
that this particular agency can do
um so if you're upset at california for
not going far enough
they this agency doesn't have that
authority gotcha people on the right
foot there
the other aspect of this is that it
mostly has been reported on for the
harassment claims they're by far the
most lascivious they're the most bright
line they are the biggest
and perhaps of the biggest issue at the
company um
but if you go and you read the complaint
if you watch my video god love you
um it's 25 pages out of 30 talking about
discrimination
predominantly equal pay right the
rest of the california lawsuit here is
that activision
and and here's where it gets tricky for
a strategy purpose and here's why that
that video is an hour and a half long
because you have to be very careful
because these are very serious
allegations they deserve the seriousness
with which they're being discussed
they deserve the state being
investigating them they also deserve a
discussion of what has actually been
alleged here right which is that
activision blizzard activision
activision publishing
and maybe the family of entities it gets
a little vague there uh in the complaint
have maliciously intentionally and
willfully
deliberately discriminated in hiring
firing
and paying women at their company right
that's the very first claim that's 25
pages out of 30.
right and that in and of itself is a
very very tough claim
to make whether you're the state of
california whether you're the federal
government whoever
you have to be able to bring evidence
that says
not just that there was a bad apple here
or a bad apple there or a manager that
was deliberately depressing women's pay
or deciding not to hire any women
before we even get into harassment right
because there's less emotionality i
think on the equal pay stuff even though
there's rightfully emotionality there as
well
right um that just talking about those
things what the state of california has
alleged is that activision is
deliberately doing this
right is deliberately and intentionally
discriminating
and then deliberately and intentionally
harass it
that they have created something with
the intent of discriminating and
harassing
and that's hard right because you get
into a situation where we can talk about
the allegations with specificity we can
do all that and obviously i can talk for
an hour and a half
but when you have these conversations
it's easy enough to look at those and
say oh my god
paragraph whatever is terrible the next
paragraph even worse the next paragraph
even worse
all those are true i have no doubt in my
mind the state of california has
testimony has investigations has
paperwork that says each and every
data point each paragraph that they have
proposed happened to their satisfaction
the question then from a legal
perspective and this is not a moral
perspective it's not an ethical
perspective
just legal the legal perspective is does
that rise especially in a business that
has 10
000 employees 9 500 i believe 10 000
employees
we don't know the time frame that this
took place on one of activision's
defenses is this is 10 years of stuff
and if you pau if you bring three
paragraphs over 10 years for 10 000
people
well you have to show that we didn't do
enough in our handbook we didn't do
enough in our firings we didn't do
enough
in whatever it is that we were supposed
to do because the the state of the law
even in california is not perfection
right you might have seen and they
operate in washington you might have
seen bungie's thread on twitter
yeah we are against harassment we're
zero tolerance all really good stuff
from bungie
one of the things they said in that
thread was we are sure harassment has
happened here
right they did they did acknowledge that
every business every business
is sure that you get enough people in
there
somebody could be a saint for their
entire life and decide today's not the
day to be a saint
right and then it's how the business
reacts and do they do anything
right the state of california has said
you didn't do anything
you didn't you deliberately didn't do
anything and in fact you supported these
bad actions
right and to me i look at that and i say
all right
let's start talking about data points
and anecdotes and
activision itself then comes out with
its statement and says
basically uh i don't even know how to
describe it actually it was very
it was very aggressive it was it was you
know somebody in my comments said what
is this cable
news [ __ ] or something like that and
i had to say
it really does sound of talking heads on
msnbc or fox or wherever you're at where
they come out with
i don't remember what it is uh unelected
bureaucrats in the state of california
trying to keep companies down or
whatever and they've alluded to the fact
that
you know this is you know a practice as
a result of this
these actions it's driving business out
of the state of california
that kind of a bit they were very
aggressive very very aggressive and
there's a couple
ways you can read that right you can
read that as desperate cornered animal
and just failing about which i think a
number of people are doing that's
totally within their rights
you can read it as well california by
statute is part of their process
doesn't want to go to court the statute
in california says okay
department of fair employment and
housing if you find something through
your investigations that's a problem
we by statute as a legislature have
mandated
that you go to mediation with this other
company and you try to sort it out
before anybody gets sued
because litigation is a costly
enterprise litigation is a time
time consuming enterprise and so
one of the things you'll read in that
activision statement is effectively
california
that admits that they had three meetings
or whatever a week before they filed a
lawsuit
right activision says california didn't
tell us what they were looking at didn't
tell us what to correct didn't tell us
what they were going to bring
and so that wasn't a legitimate
mediation um
and we're stuck here on the outside
right
away california is um
gilding the lily in parts of their
complaint as you would expect them to do
as you would expect a plaintiff if
you've been in virtually god if you've
looked at any lawsuits epic for example
anything else the plaintiff's complaint
has
some paragraphs and some stances early
on that are intended for
kotaku or ign or gamespot or whatever
pickup yeah he's gonna get a reaction
and so they could have gone to mediation
and not
and and wanted to go to trial and
activision says you didn't do the right
thing under the statute
activision could be bloviating like
nobody's business right there is
no way to tell from out here which is
one of the things i say in my video but
i also say
yeah you know the equal pay stuff the
discrimination stuff the stuff that
makes up that 25 pages of their
complaint
is much further away to my eye just one
person's opinion right who's a lawyer
right and the harassment stuff the
harassment stuff is a cleaner argument
that they have
but the bulk of the punitive damages the
actual arguments they make the 25 pages
of the document
focusing on that discrimination aspect
that's that's further away from me just
in what they allege
got you no no great great point one last
question before i open it up to everyone
else
because you're dropping a lot of gems
here so again just based on what you
were saying again it's just your opinion
this is the initial
you know things that we've read you know
so basically
it there's there's two different things
here this is the
female paid discrimination aspect right
and then there's also the the harassment
so you feel it's going to be
they may face they have may have some
potential challenges
with we're trying to combine both of
those unless they focus
on and try to prove that there's a
systemic problem with the paid
discrimination for you
but my question is like do you think
they should change their approach and
focus on one instead of this broad scope
of all these things
that they've included in this initial
complaint well so of course i wouldn't
tell the state of california how to do
their business
but what they did was they took the
broad shotgun approach which is there's
a couple of bits of law in there that i
go over in my video that allow you to
bring
everything and the kitchen sink on
discrimination harassment and a third
category which is retaliation
right uh so what they accused blizzard
activision of is
discrimination harassment and
retaliation right and it's it's pretty
boilerplate by the time you get to the
counts when they're actually talking
about
what what what they're alleging versus
the facts which is what's been reported
on
with actual allegations so it's it's
their it's their shotgun approach
it's just that you know reading through
those
it's it's difficult to frame them as
willful and malicious and intentional
just based on what they even allege
because you have to get to the point
where
they're deliberately ignoring things
they're putting in policies and
procedures that encourage harass i mean
whatever that looks like
that doesn't quite make its way into
that document instead what they present
is
some very very bad data points um which
are admittedly
properly being reported on um from from
various folks
uh but the the question ultimately in a
court of law
or settlement negotiation or whatever it
is is
is that is that a bad actor five bad
actors over 10 years whatever
or is that a company that's deliberately
hiring harassers and encouraging the
harassing behavior in terms of that frat
boycott and the discrimination by the
way you said
pay pay is the focus that's where they
keep coming back to because that's where
the damages live
but they also include everything else
related to discrimination which is
hiring and firing
constructive termination promotions
everything that relates to
um the employment relationship yep got
it and thank you for that
let's open it up solve i'm sorry i
hijacked your topic but i had to
get you know the legend of virtual
legality to get his insight first but um
you know so i'm gonna start with you and
then i'll open it up as well like
where where are you at with this and you
know you brought this to the realm and
obviously it's a very rough week to read
a lot of this stuff so
where you have this um i think what
what hog said in regards to the shotgun
approach uh makes
sense now that that the way he frames it
because
i think encompassing all of these things
as one thing
i think makes it a a subject that's
that's gonna get more eyes on it as
opposed to
x amount of women got sexually harassed
which is something that you see all the
time now when you try to when you when
you take
all of these things and make it a
systemic problem where it's
it goes all the way from the moment you
walk into the door how you're treated
in terms of as a professional to how
you're treated as a female
making it broader i think gets all
different kinds of eyes on it in a way
that maybe
scoping it down won't do so i think that
makes sense although
again there are certain things that are
probably difficult to prove overall
um i think at the end of the day though
it just it's really disappointing and
appalling to see the things that came up
in this lawsuit
because we've been seeing it for so long
now
especially in the gaming space right and
i feel like
on one end this stuff doesn't feel like
it like it's
isolated to the gaming space but at the
same time when you see so many big
gaming
companies have issues like that whether
it be on the press side
or the development side because we've
seen it with ign and you've seen it with
ea
we've seen it with ubisoft it it sort of
feels like
the way this this problem pans out
specifically in this industry
is it just an industry-centric problem
and and the way it needs to be addressed
is sort of from within in a way that
maybe
other industries in the way they handle
it maybe it just would be different
um it's just to me i i don't understand
how this type of and the way they quoted
frat boy's sort of mentality
continues to permeate in these
professional settings
where when you have creative endeavors
right when you're not just you know
throwing something onto a whatever a
conveyor belt and building something
when the endeavor is creative
um there's a there's a thoughtfulness
that goes with that
the type of people that sort of work in
that environment and to see and what
happens is we've talked oftentimes about
how
the boardroom often invades the the the
the
the creative space and what what happens
to an environment when that happens is
that
the boardroom supersedes what the
creative space
would allow for and i really just do
think that
in these instances with these big
companies
at the top of the top is has a
totally different understanding of
what's happening
at the rungs below them and you can see
that in the way that they're defending
a lot of these things like you expect an
executive to told a company line and
defend the company right
right but when you see these types of
actions being spoken about
and then you have an executive a female
at that saying hey that is not the
that is not the activision blizzard that
i know
you know what it's not going to be the
activision blizzard that you know
because do you walk these studios every
single day
do you interact with these people every
single day you're referring to the chief
people officer
but it just feels like there's a there's
a blindness
uh when it comes to upper management to
what is going on below them
and you know at the end of the day
as a man seeing that we just have to be
better
we just have to be better it is you know
the fact that you could get away with
with this type of behavior in
a professional environment is bonkers to
me right
and the fact that it continues to happen
specifically in this
industry and the way it happens in this
industry
um it's just it's confusing to me
it's disappointing to me and on a lot of
levels i don't i
never want to put any sort of blame on
victims here right
whatsoever because this should not be
happening um
but there's something that frustrates me
about the gaming space
and people who come into the gate gaming
space whether it is
on the on the uh the press side or the
development side
it's like you're passionate about this
right obviously it's a creative endeavor
you're passionate about it
when you get that job you think it's
your dream job and you don't want to
give it up for anything
right and maybe it's just me maybe it's
just me
and i you know again and this may be a
bad take
no no this is but this is you fight
that's how you feel but
i'm not built like that to i'm not built
to take
anyone treating me as less than in any
way shape or form
and maybe i don't have maybe i don't
have that sort of survival instinct that
work where i don't
care right but i'm not you know if
something has happened to me it's
happening to me
at my job coming from from somebody in
upper management whatever
and i go through the proper steps to
address that right and
it doesn't get addressed and it
continues right and i address it
directly with the person and it
continues
at that point there's no more
conversation either i'm going to
put i'm going to address it in a very
public form and
form to embarrass you or worse comes to
worst
i'm putting hands on you i feel you bro
you were forged built differently
again at that same point you got to talk
about people that have been
disenfranchised marginalized and set
aside
right uh you're talking about a
demographic
of of a there's a certain set
and i this is going to be a real
sensitive topic that i'm going to
approach
right now and individuals may not
like what i'm about to feel this is your
opinion
yeah this this is just my opinion of it
um this space this gaming space for a
very long time
was not for women
people of color
different right you understand
now a lot of those people
that are in part doing these behaviors
it's learned trained behavior
right this learnt trained behavior
is all about trying to be included and
not be
ostracized not giving
the individuals uh
an excuse right what i'm saying is
everything about it is completely wrong
i've talked about this on my minute with
the lords yes
it's a complete uh sensitive topic for
me
because we pushed to get through that
glass ceiling
we pushed to get through the glass
ceiling every woman that
pushed to get through that glass ceiling
when you feel like you
made it into this space and you accept
it in the space
to find out that you're not to find out
that you're being objectified and looked
at
as you it's it's very terrifying
horrifying
you understand so the the victim may not
act in the way that you expect them to
act
right because if they know that their
words aren't being heard
going up the chain if their direct
uh supervisor that's right in front of
you doesn't push it up the chain
is a systematic problem going all the
way up and
that person feels small maybe they have
bills they have to pay they have a
family they'd have to take care of
and they take all of this and they stuff
it down and they
come in and they come to work and
they're doing their job
it's horrifying that
the frat boy mentality still exists
in our day and age right it's gratifying
seeing this stuff come out
as explicit as it is in the paperwork
and as repulsive as it is
in the paperwork because you're passing
noobs around
of a co-worker right at a party
allegedly a legend a legend lawyer
good lawyer talk all conspiracy this is
what thank you that's why you know right
even they say allegedly it's okay no
you're right you protected us oh thank
you
this is the stuff that people said
allegedly yeah
it's horrifying i have a mother i have
grandmothers i have daughters
i have sons mm-hmm um
to for for this to happen to individuals
and not just saying that it was
happening just to women it was it was
happening the mentor i'm pretty sure
that same andrew
that same feeling of you coming from
haiti
and they're hearing your voice different
and you're being targeted right
individuals
this is your safe space you stay at work
a majority of your day
this is supposed to be your family that
you built with right
that you grow with this is you spend
your time more at work than you do at
home
right unhealthy environment
it's very saddening you know i i went
along on the topic but
it really hurts me deeply that people
have to get up to a job because i go
to work with a duty in my heart for you
to go to work with a duty in your heart
and for you to put up with individuals
and stuff like this
it's absolutely repulsive right just to
jump into
both of you guys point out again still
open it up because i had to get andrew i
got to get one bad mother in
um in reference to you know we always
talk about discuss the volatility of the
games industry and
we talk about you know how you know
sometimes people
you know don't stay at one place and you
know just let's be honest like just the
volatility of the
success of video games right a lot of
these games are not successful so when
you
you you're put in a position with a
somewhat
stable company right an activision
blizzard has been around
you know to some this is this is going
to be a dream job it's going to be a
dream scenario
for a lot of people and um i i know
where you're going with that so
to solve back to saul's point which he
was saying like you know
because we know how he's built right we
know we know where he comes from
and but also we got to put ourselves in
the mindset sometimes of
younger more impressionable minds trying
to get their start
in the industry and and to them this is
their world this is
it right and and if these type of
you know practices and and grooming and
all this stuff is going on right
you know this sometimes people people
don't have the strength
to sometimes make that moral choice
to to to push back because for them
this was it this was their pinnacle at
that time at that stage of life but let
me let me open it up because i could go
on but i won't go too long but
let's get our andrew alliance in um
andrew i don't know if you caught a lot
of these accounts this week
you know obviously we're seeing the
legal side that hog brought out as far
as litigation on both sides
state of california activision and a
blizzard are pushed back
on with their statement you know what's
your take on everything that's going on
well it's a lot right it's multi-layered
in so many different ways when you look
at
the industry as mentioned and even the
previous stuff that went forth uh my
thing is like when there's always um
when fear uncertainty and doubt is
introduced and how the story is supposed
to come out right
and even from the lower standpoint i
spoke earlier when things aren't clear
cut
like even in contracts things are
clear-cut if you don't like the contract
then you have to
navigate and find a way to change the
terms right but when things aren't
clear-cut
even when they are introduced in our
eyes when it hits the news
it's more messy
it is essentially right so so
based on the things that we already saw
in the news we're like okay so yeah
that's messy and that's bad and and even
as king was saying so yeah
i have to feed my family i feel hopeless
i can't go to the individuals that are
supposed to protect me when i have a
challenge
at that particular workplace right so
then there's that and then you have the
stories of the individuals coming out on
twitter
uh sharing some of their that's why i
left that's why i'm no longer there
that's why
so you have all these different quotes
that you're seeing on social media it's
more layered than we know yeah right
good point and
think that because of that it makes
things more interesting when you're
trying to solve
or trying to um the behavior is not
going to change
even with lawsuits right we've seen that
in multiple aspects of all the different
companies that we've seen in the past
where there has been an issue
in that particular culture in that
particular marketplace we always know
that there's more to
that than they're telling us but at the
same time if the people aren't checked
that are doing those behaviors if
they're if there isn't any
it's if there isn't any like an
independent a firm
that's independent to make sure that
those
things are in check then the frat boy
culture or whatever that culture is is
going to be
it's always going to be in place in that
particular establishment right and i
think that
without that the the employees
the creatives all all of the individuals
who are
who are putting time in for that
particular organization that particular
company they're never
going to feel safe in that particular
environment if there's no way for them
to
get checked i have a question for hope
because i don't know
like when it comes to like uh you know
committees and stuff like
is it hard to apply that on to a
corporation such as activision
do you have to do they have to like 100
agree to it like
can they can they can can the state
force it like
because i feel like if we're forcing
like you know a committee to
to that's not related to outside
oversight yeah outside oversight someone
that just looks into this kind of stuff
but
because to me if it was like why would
activision or any company of that
statute
like let someone just look into the
affairs like that especially if some of
this is being handled
by the people who's doing it like the
the you know the
uh the abusers well you know i would
answer that
higher up um a corporation an llc
any entity is a legal fiction that's a
term of art we use to say it's not real
activision doesn't exist activision is a
piece of paper i think you see one of
the statements say it's a piece of paper
and a file cabinet in delaware
um which hopefully it's not it should be
to file a cabinet at their headquarters
but we can talk about that later
um but it it's that means that the state
has
some broad authority to say well we
don't have to let
your corporation operate in our state
unless you use x y and z that's one of
the reasons you see california exerting
stronger things
i will say that um there are
potential negative ramifications that
are constantly balanced by political
forces on these things one of those
is highlighted by activision statement
which finishes off with
you know basically a threat that we're
going to take our ball and go to texas
and so the states are constantly
evaluating that as well
california more aggressive than most so
they might do something like that you
never know
uh but it's just important to realize
that like any market
political standing for a corporation
is a market and there is shopping for
tax rates
and treatment of uh shareholder rights
and what it is that you're looking for
when you want to operate a business
um and so you do see states competing on
those grounds including texas and
florida and some others
no doubt i want to get one bad mother in
before i give it back to attic um what
about mother man like
rough you know very very rough week
we've seen these accounts we've seen
what's going on you know what what's
your thought process what's your mindset
there's so many layers to this but
as we unpack where's your head at with
all this stuff
yeah you know when i first heard about
this it's
it's you know for me personally i have a
daughter that just turned 16 and you
know she'll be going in the workplace in
a few years and so
you know i look at something like this
and it and and
you know the first thing is like well
how how should i rant like what is the
proper way to go
and you know as we heard home talk
there's there's this legal side
but there's this other side too and this
actually kind of
dovetails into what king was talking
about i had
i had a friend actually dm me a couple
days ago and i'm saying they were kind
of wondering
what what is the right way to sort of
respond to the situation you know how
you feel
you know there's elite you know there's
a legal process but you also know
there's a person
i'm glad you're touching this this is
what she i'm just going to read a couple
sentences she said to me about
the conversation she said we'll all
forget and it'll happen again
and we'll be shocked again if we failed
her that's
all we have the power to say we have the
power to say no
and and we can't we failed her that
could have been me
and no one would have cared and they
would have kept working like they did
this is somebody who's actually gone
through the process herself
she's you know and she even touched on
some of the things that came out in a
statement
like you know like this is what happens
you know you bring it up and somebody
says oh you must have misread that
person or this couldn't have happened
this
that person wouldn't have said that you
must have you know mistook it
and then it gets yeah it gets dismissive
and you know really when you look into
the the situation at a macro level
you know and i'm sure most of us have
heard this before but most women don't
come out
you know out of all the women that when
they when they done the research that
say
i face sexual harassment it's only a
small percentage
so when you look at something like what
we're seeing now with
with all these people kind of stepping
forward keep in mind
this is just the tip of the iceberg
probably
you know there's probably a lot more
people and so
so i do understand because i've heard
the other side where people are like
well i'm not going to say anything
because i'm not in a position to
or why should i you know like why should
i say something now right
and i would say like this this is
why it's important because
you know when when people feel supported
they are more emboldened
you know when people when people start
to feel the support they
they're they are more likely to start
coming forward and that's why you saw
that within b2
movement a few years back right where
other women were just
you know encouraged by by others and
seeing some of the support so
you know i i do i do understand what you
know when people say there's a process
and things like that but
at the end of the day you know when we
look at that it's like where we're at
where we've come it's just not good
enough right so like what is
what do we got to do to to bridge that
gap
and you know like again going to kind of
what hold was saying it's like you know
yeah corporation is is
is really just a it's a machine right
it's a piece of paper it's a machine
but like i had somebody you know
leadership once said to me like when i'm
trying to find out like well how do you
get this person to do something
one way or another he says you'll never
be able to make somebody do something
but like leaders do set in the
environment
that will a lot that will encourage
people to
to go one way or another at least on on
the whole and and
off of everything that we've learned so
far it looks like there's been a
complete leadership failure at
activision
um it does appear that they've created
a toxic environment and i honestly just
the response alone just
feels like it almost is indicting just
seeing the response because it just
feels like you're you just don't
understand
right like when you start hearing it
from from women who've been through this
and you hear something like that it's
like
you you don't even get it and somebody
should have like he should have reached
out to somebody in pr before you can
send that response but to me
to me it's clear that something needs to
happen
with their leadership uh and i don't
think just saying hey we're going to
start doing harassment training is going
to be no
they really there needs to be something
more that happens it sends a message
and again it supports the you know the
women that are involved in these
situations
and it continues in both of them because
that numbers is really
when you get into these he said sheep
that said things a lot of these that
a lot of times those numbers is what
they have right so
and i think we're going to find out that
there's more numbers to this situation
yeah this this is interesting i'm sorry
somebody's just no no
yeah i just why do you think this
behavior sort of permeates the the
gaming industry so much in a way that's
so
blatant right because i just you know if
i if you look at an amazon
or an apple i i don't know
but for some reason i highly doubt that
this type of behavior
is is so pervasive across the board
you're going to have instances and
pockets of it of course
right but it just feels like like you
said uh one bad mother it's like
it's it's a company it's kind of
permeated the entire culture
of these companies that are being called
out how does that
happen like i just don't understand how
it turns into a and in
the entire sort of administration sort
of
supporting this type of behavior or
turning a blind eye to it
yeah i definitely want to jump in there
to answer that quickly and
um i think it's because it's dismissed
right even if you look at all the twit
longers that we've seen
in the last two years even during um you
know the um the thing we had with the
vaccine and all that stuff we've seen
that whole thing
that whole thing right um i think that
a lot of it is dismissed and as and it
compounds over time and then what you
find
is you get uh someone that finally says
that's it if nobody's gonna say
something i'm going to say something
right
as soon as they say something then we
see all the stuff
that spans you know five years back or
six years back of things that are taking
place i think uh the dismissive culture
of these things that
are happening that's that's it that's
part of it and the other thing too
is um we have to be careful as well is
we
we hear the statement believe all women
right
that sounds great right but if a
percentage of those women are not
telling the truth about every matter we
have
to be careful with that as well
absolutely absolutely um
let me jump in real quick because uh
everybody's on fire these are these are
fantastic points
it's a tough week tough week man um
before i start about that i just want to
ask
hulk one quick question so this was uh
from the state of california perspective
this was a
two to three year ongoing investigation
what they put down in their dates was
middle of 2018
um that they put a uh i don't remember
what their name up for it was but a
cause document they received complaints
and they informed
activision that they'd be investigating
them right um there's some statutory
rules for timing so it looks like at
some point in the middle of that
investigation they both agreed that they
could sue later than the statute
required it's one of the things i raised
in my video
but it's a long term investigation which
you could read in two different ways
right
you know i think on twitter and social
media and elsewise uh there are people
how would i how do i quit this uh there
are people that are far more willing to
just believe
a state-based complaint than i am just
from experience
and that's not that's not saying
anything about the state of california's
complaint that's just saying
everybody everywhere's a human being
right and has their own thought process
and everything else so um i don't view
it being california versus a class
action
or plaintiff's lawsuit or anything as
specifically more or
than anything else uh regardless of a
two-year investigation and of course
you could look at it the other way which
is that for a two-year investigation
what they have in allegations
is is four pages um of paragraphs which
to be frank he's into tongue for that
length of time for an investigation so
it's it's a matter of i think they're
setting the groundwork
um and they're going to go into
discovery and find more and certainly
that's part of the process here but
um yeah they've been investigating for a
long time they went into that mediation
they only announced that they would
they had gotten to that point i believe
the date they put in was late june
right so they tell activision at the end
of last month we're going forward with
this
then the mandatory mediation kicks in
they do it i think three or four times
in the first couple of weeks of july
obviously doesn't come to fruition
and then they say all right here we go
and they filed a lawsuit on the 20th
which was the day before
their agreement right had been at the
outdate that they weren't allowed to sue
anymore
right it's a long process and to me
what's going to be interesting
you know if the pushback from activision
and blizzard if they're going to go all
the way back with the pushback
and if this just settles you know so i'm
very curious to see where that go
get off yeah so one of the things i said
is almost all of these settle um the
predominant
form of finishing a dispute at any level
in a civil
action is a settlement right um i will
say
that based on the introduction from a
couple of the first couple of paragraphs
the california document which i highly
recommend everybody should read because
it's
very uh it's very feisty from a state
agency and it's very much
depending on how you want to read it
generously not so generously it's very
much
says basically we at the department
don't much care for video games
right that looks like video game
industry in particular is a problem um
on the other hand activision says
essentially what i described as go to
the mattresses
godfather style that they're they're
willing to burn the town down on this
yes here's what you learn in law school
is that litigation is a bad idea for
everybody in a civil action
because at the end of the day there's a
number there's a penalty
there's a solution that's hit and the
only difference between hitting it now
in a settlement room and hitting it
later is that lawyers got paid
and time went by and so the only time
you really have a high stakes litigation
of this type
is if there is emotionality and or one
or both of the parties
really feels self-righteous and
passionate about their specific position
so if you do
if activision isn't just lying and that
statement when they originally made it
reads to me
as unvetted not gone through pr not gone
through lawyers they're honest to god
angry position yeah against california's
righteousness
that is in fact when you can get a
nuclear exchange
because you have this kind of we're
right on both sides
and if that does in fact happen then
sky's the limit
in terms of in terms of penalties in
terms of everything else now
in any ordinary universe somebody is
talking to bobby or whomever at
activision and saying
if we go into discovery and we have to
talk about
10 15 20 years of compensation decisions
of hiring and firing decisions of every
email that they can find
on anything then that's not a winner no
matter what the charges were for any
corporation in america
and so usually you go to the settlement
table because
if it's if as long as they're not asking
for you to bankrupt the company
almost anything is going to be better
right i still say it's likely to settle
because
cooler heads will prevail um and that
settlement feature in california doesn't
mean it has to be secret i think a lot
of people think that settlements have to
be secret
um california can mandate an apology and
an acknowledgment of issues and
hundreds of millions of dollars of fines
and restitution they can do whatever
they want
in terms of that settlement um i would
still have
90 percent of the money on
settlement no settlement yeah because
the discovery is is extremely damaging
to extremely you just don't know
somebody murdered someone right
even with the emotionality of of of of
the position right now
you know as a corporation yes you know
when discovery comes out and more
you know comes out and you know if if
more comes out then yeah that that's
something that is
extremely damaging so yeah i agree with
you hold on now
i think it's far more likely to see a
settlement and i think that there is a
significantly non-zero chance they do in
fact leave gotcha um you know they've
been there since the 70s do you uh
and it's not just the dfeh it's tax
situation there's a lot of companies
that are evaluating california
that's the kind of thing where i think
that this this might be something that
moves them yeah so
a quick question for you do you look at
any other cases besides gaming stuff do
you look at non-gaming stuff
as well or so so here's the fun part
right i'll understand so i'm a corporate
lawyer i do contracts transactions
formations setting up things
and i have a lot of software and
technology in my book of business and i
work with video games i sponsored easy
allies
i met the iron lords i have virtual
legality so i do
i look at lawsuits in technology and big
technology i did epic versus apple i
talk about some of the trump 230
lawsuits the biden uh
orders and things like that yeah the
reason i ask is if you ever look at the
ripple case versus the sec
uh ripple it's a cryptocurrency i would
love to hear your takes in the future if
you ever look at that i would probably
have a crypto video of some kind
at some point yeah um but yeah the
andrew
it's one of those where virtual legality
is
um especially like this one you know a
lot of my videos i can do pretty quickly
uh this one is like okay so we've got a
lot of emotionality we've got a lot of
precision
we've got a lot of important things that
this one took me i don't know seven
hours
eight hours to do um so it's crypto is
one of those where it's fun but it's not
very well
documented so it'll be a fun research
project i'll look at it no doubt yeah
i'd love to
i'm going to watch the video that you
mentioned especially on the topic that
we're currently talking about definitely
not for sure man i'm glad i'm glad more
people get to know about it
absolve addict i mean let me add it
because i think addict wouldn't say
something first
i always feel safer with him in the
building yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
we use all this
[Laughter]
definitely
like from like see you said you think
most likely this
is going to um it's going to settle out
of court
so do you are if they do settle out of
court because like to me
do you think those individuals are going
to leave the company like active vision
and
blizzard what individuals like i'm
talking about the you know
some of the management that's let this
happen so uh you know because
i feel like there's a lot of people that
follow here and to me i feel like if
it's settled out of court
there's gonna be very little
restructuring in the in the company
itself
and to me it's just like if the
culture's not changed
why would this change even know that
there's money that's written
out and distributed to people well
california has to be a little bit
careful for what they mandate the
private organizations to do but they can
mandate things they can say
as part of your settlement we're gonna
be sitting on board meetings for three
years and you're gonna make sure that
you switch the chairman's
seat out i mean they can i have no idea
what that would look like you can ask
for
ten dollars and everybody's unhappy you
can ask for the moon
a settlement is not a limited kind of
concept i'm not
i'm not really referring to is like the
settlement thing i'm referring to that
to me unless there's restructuring i
feel like
we're just going to run into this again
in a couple years more of the same thing
you're going to remove these people from
this position like because i i have a
cousin that she
she's a lawyer in um in tucson and
she said that one of the issues that she
has
when she's done she's like the settling
thing
isn't good and bad but it hurts just as
much as it it's good because
a lot of the times you can't like
criminally charge people if you
do take some of the money and she says
the
part of the issue she's seen in her uh
you know career is
a lot of people are getting off
especially rich rich people because they
just paying the money
like and then when we talk about
billionaires doing
really sky me stuff and i'm not talking
about necessarily activision
what's a couple hundred million to them
when they can continue doing the stuff
they're doing
well that's fair there's a number of
ways to go i mean that's one of the
reasons i mentioned that this is the
civil action this is the department of
fair employment
that's distinct from a california
attorney general or whatever other
agency they might have that would look
at criminal complaints would look at
justice type
in your opinion if they do settle out of
court
do you think that activision and whoever
is over there or their lawyers
you think they would make them sign in
any form of paperwork saying they can't
criminally
charge them all right so let's do some
real talk here on the ironman
i don't know i don't know
yeah so uh there's a reason right now
that the management is not named in the
lawsuit and that reason is the nature of
what they've presented which is
i described as anecdotal that might be
one notch to um
dismiss it that's not the intent of it
it's simply to suggest that
the alleged factual allegations are
targeted at one individual who is my
understanding is not with the company
anymore
right uh which i actually object to that
targeting if you're going to target
somebody in a complaint like that you
should name them so that they get
the information but that's separate if
that's a bad actor it's a bad actor he
just hasn't had his day in
court okay um outside of that they they
haven't named
much of anybody um and what they've got
at least as alleged doesn't suggest
direct
issues in the document itself right now
um so you want to hit bobby kotec bobby
kotick isn't mentioned
um and uh the primary kind of way that
they get to the harassment complaints
they got the story about the guy that's
gone from the company
and they've got the story about the
hotel room and i'll just leave it again
yeah we know about it
and um before that they got the cube
crawl so it's essentially three
paragraphs
it's cube crawl guy blizzard and hotel
room yeah
and so you're going to say the cube
crawl rises to the level
of um criminal actions against specific
managers
you're probably going to have to target
people that are directly responsible for
that kind of behavior
rather than who you want to hit
generally speaking
doesn't mean it isn't the case i'm not
sitting there with whatever the heck
they got in their binders right right
but it's what i would caution
is it's it's easy to look at all this
and say
the whole company is bad and x y and z
should be
uh fired or sued or gone to prison and
all these kinds of things
uh obviously if they are intentionally
maliciously doing these things
absolutely bring that send it to the
attorney general i'm all for it
as presented right this second we're not
at that level as i see it in the
document itself so when we talk about
settlement
we're talking about california wants to
make activision hurt
you saw last year that california
interceded in a settlement that the
class action tried to have with riot
for 10 million dollars and said no court
they shouldn't be settling for less than
400 million
and riot's a lot smaller than activision
and you get there and you say well what
in the heck is california asking for in
that mediation
and would that be sufficient to hurt
them when you have that settlement
yes there will be some kind of contract
that says if you do the x y and z and
you pay us 500 million dollars
then we're not going to do certain
things on our grounds
i'm not sure because i'm not a
california lawyer but procedurally
exactly what
the department of fare employment can
waive on behalf of the state of
california probably not criminal
complaints
um so they're probably not getting out
of that in terms of a civil settlement
but i understand your concern because
you see this and somebody is responsible
you can't just say okay it's a big
monolithic entity right and it did all
this bad stuff somebody did something
something i get it i don't i don't think
it's all activision all blizzard
but i do think there are certain
management that probably knows that
there's certain people in key positions
that probably know
if there's a kid crawl with groping
going on somebody did something that
facilitated and knew about it somebody
got something going on yeah all i'm
saying
is like my thing is like i just want it
to stop
i get it no i do your concern is the
settlement
aspect doesn't result in sort of
resolving
the issue it just you know slaps the on
the wrist
maybe a couple of people but the intel
the culture of the fretboard culture and
stuff
may still continue you want to get to
get to the community if they
if they've been doing that this hardcore
and
it seems like it's been a long time
they've been doing this this hardcore
to me a settlement is all
all that's going to do is be like we got
to be more careful now
like well so there's a saying right the
law is a sledgehammer it's not a scalpel
and and that california has a
sledgehammer they're gonna they're gonna
wield it
um it's not no matter what happens
settlement trial anything
i can guarantee you that the end state
whether you go through all that or you
settle it out of court
is not gonna be perfect match for what
basically anybody wants got you so
what um just one thing i just wanted to
bring up that uh
we didn't touched on and this is my last
thing
sorry you know
you brought up some really good
questions and saab did too you know like
why is it in this gaming industry right
that we see like this
this culture seems even more pervasive
even though
it does exist elsewhere we know that
right but it but it seems like it's even
uh seems like there's a greater issue
here i think that answer is kind of
simple if you really just kind of look
at it on the surface because
i think even paris mentioned something
about it uh this week is that you know
when you look at their board of their
leadership
there's not there's no diversity there
right it's all the same
it you know it's you know it
and the thing is the gaming industry is
as king was saying earlier has
is really up until very recently has not
been very diverse
and so when you just think about that
the really the only
in my mind the the the easiest answer to
change that is to start
if you want to change that culture you
want to change that environment as you
need
you need to change that leadership and
it does and this is why i you know a lot
of times
you know you hear the pushback on
diversity you know like
like you check in a box it's not
checking a box like this
this helps you be better leadership be
better leaders
it helps you have because you have more
perspectives right and so i do think
that regardless what happens illegally
uh because you know as i swing that
hammer that sledgehammer
that you know those things may not take
place there i i do think that
you know media influences whoever it is
needs to put pressure on
activision's brand to change and
hopefully that will
create environment to to make others go
oh you know what maybe we should get
ahead of this because
we're not very diverse either right like
let's let's see what we can do to be
proactive
so we're not you know we we don't have
all of our skeletons
you know shown to the to the world like
activision
yeah hopefully it's a butterfly effect
yeah that actually takes root
and uh because of this because like you
know hulk said
this you know it's not as a scalpel
it's a sledgehammer and with a
sledgehammer it's meant to
uh hit it may not hit exactly precisely
how everybody wants it to hit
because no one is going to be completely
satisfied especially the victims
you know um in this case and and when
you really look at it just look at it
put your shoes
put your feet in the shoes of the
victims um
the corporations they come and they go
if this is something that destroys
activision then maybe you should have
stopped it before it got to this point
but it didn't so we're at this point and
now you have to deal with
the cause of your actions at the point
that we are at right now
so it sounds absolutely horrible and a
lot of the actions allegedly are
absolutely horrible but again we have to
let the legal process
plan its diligence and go through its
course
and whatever happens after that if you
feel a certain way
don't be quiet don't push it down voice
your opinion be loud
be heard and stand up for something that
you feel that is injustice
in an area that you see and if you see
stuff like this going on
speak up put yourself in the shoes of
the victim
i will always remember these guys
bullying
a dude playing with not it's not the
same stuff
playing with his game boy i had a
kinship to him
because he was a nerd like me i was just
a big nerd that
was able to fight and i had to stand up
for the one that didn't
if you see it you don't say anything
you're part of the problem
if you don't stand up for the weak that
can't talk
you're part of the problem you must
stand up
for your brother your sister your friend
your co-worker because everybody
supposed to be
at peace especially in a workplace
environment
where they are going to do a job they're
not supposed to go into a toxic
environment
and be afraid or harassed that's right
not fair enough solving then i gotta go
get down because we've been going yeah
so so
i guess my final question is do we think
that this is this this huge lawsuit by
the state of california
is the and the ideal way to at least
begin to institute
uh real change in a way that things that
we say sometimes like you know vote with
your wallet don't don't purchase their
games don't do that
don't really move the needle at all do
we think this is
probably the best bet that we have to
see
a company be be forced into
instituting real change that can cause
that ripple effect throughout the
the industry and sort of make other
companies look at each other because
when you look at this it's like
well they've already seen what happened
with ubisoft right even though this is a
two-year investigation right they've
seen what happened when we saw they've
seen what happened yeah they've seen
what happened
with with uh with reporting outlets as
well like ign and stuff like that
you it's like you you you willfully
turned a blind eye to what's happening
in your company
and you kind of say hey it's not going
to happen to us nobody's going to come
bother us and then when it does happen
you're like oh man we should have
so my thing is is this the proper way
to really force this company this big
humongous company to institute to shame
them
and institute change in a real way where
it's
where the repercussions of that are felt
throughout the industry
and it really does push the rest of the
industry to change in a real way
not just addressing this one specific
issue in the moment yeah that to me
that's the that's the million dollar
question
you know i'll jump in um yeah i'm not
sure i'm not sure
because it to me it's it's i do find it
interesting
that you know prior you know while this
is going on i'm seeing companies that
you know almost are not directly
affected but are coming out with almost
preemptive statements you know we here
at such and such
we don't do that right we hear it
whatever so you know it's interesting
it it's going to me it's going to be one
of those moments where i'm just going to
sit back
and monitor where this goes and see if
it does have that
that ripple effect and um you know it
was you know it was shocking obviously
state of california this investigation
all this stuff
you know i'll make it quick um at the
end of the day
the the the i do agree with hogue i
think
there's going to be a settlement that's
just my feeling i feel that
well she could have the moment i heard
it yeah once we get
into these accounts are what these
accounts are right
brutal disturbing tough you know once
you get into the discovery phase
if the state of california has more dirt
so to speak
and that is presented and obviously you
know
activision blizzard will refute if they
have you know evidence and stuff like
that
once the laundry starts getting out you
know what i'm saying
both sides really don't want that right
so both sides in my opinion
it is in their best interest to to come
to agreement but to addict's point
you know is that going to foster real
change that is the million dollar
question is that going to you know we've
heard
different things we've heard about you
know people wanting out you know
unionization we've heard about all these
different
things and and that's we see it in a lot
of things not just gaming but yeah like
nothing ever really changes because
things are always settled out of court
well we're going to see you know i i i
don't have the answer to that question
or all i'm going to say is
i mean i don't either yeah no no i know
i know you mean no
at the end of the day it's like you know
to me personally
it hit me hard for two reasons one you
know again
allegedly i got this hoax here i got to
use the word legend
allegedly you know the suicide account
bothered me
that bothered me because again if that
is happening
you know in this level of abuse and
stuff like that where someone
feels so that they they're unable they
feel so helpless that they can't do
anything that
life is taking their own life you know
and then obviously pictures shared and
all this other stuff
allegedly then you know that that's
extremely disturbing you know i'm saying
and and and that's another chamber with
the fat boy culture thing
you know um the sad part is uh you know
what's crazy king like
i'm not even surprised and i feel i
should be
i feel i shouldn't you've heard this
story before right and to saul's point
it's like i've heard it before
you know why in video games is this
happening you know i'm saying we kind of
i believe we see it in video games
because this is where our interests lie
right of course i believe it's happening
on a wide scale in the sports direction
right there it's it's it's a it's a it's
a wide
spectrum that this stuff is happening
but at the same time
our focus is here and this is what we're
talking about at the moment
and it's just disheartening because uh
everyone here expects the best
from our chosen industry of course
right we you you expect the best you
expect the person that is best fit for
the job to get the job
and be respected and walk in and you
know because
that's what you feel so when you hear
the
opposite to that it's disheartening yeah
you know and and and it's it's just it's
just a shame all the way around the
balls it's
absolute losers in this whole thing
there's
no winners at all at a settlement in
fact
you know because the majority of the
money or whatever you get
from it is going to go to therapy for a
situation that
this is going to scar individuals
forward right
until they can fix and hail with that
and like to addict's point
attic is skeptical that uh uh if you if
you pay the money out
that doesn't change from the top down
what's going on because from the people
at the top it's going to still
be in position and we all know an
organization that is rotten at the top
that permeates straight down to the soil
which is to my final point
again i'll finish up is that i think
it's going to be interesting to me what
i'm curious to monitor this whole thing
is i'll be watching every virtual galaxy
i want all these people i'll be watching
to me from a legal standpoint the thing
that
interests me the most is can the state
of act um
actually the state of california prove
that this is a systemic issue if they
got
discovery you know that this is a
systemic issue
i don't think it gets that far it
probably won't i think they pay out
and if and if california pushes too hard
they leave and they go to texas the
moment
anytime you verbalize a thought that
thought could be put into action because
you already conceived that concept of it
in your head right so when you
verbalize that thought and you've made
that threat clear
that means they already conceived that
action of leaving
so if california pushes too far in a
direction
right that is not how they've initially
threatened that in a way you know
i know where you're going you know look
right it's just the moment this this
went public the way it did
activision already in their quote in
their rooms at the top of the
the mansions is like how much is an
acceptable loss
let's get this done let's get this over
with very well but again
to hoax point emotionality right
like we i would i would assume
that from a pr standpoint activision
blizzard's
aggressive response was probably if they
had any pr person in the room
thank you hulk hulk shaking any sensible
pr is saying yo that's not
it what you just started exactly what
you just put out there
that ain't it so to me when
i know but when i see that level of
emotionality
that leads me to believe initially maybe
they cool down later
but initially they are ready to go there
this is you know these are miss gross
representations
right these are their words so when if
they're taking it like no no
you're not doing this to us oh and by
the way
we'll we'll move we heard about this
state we'll move our whole joint up out
of here
because we heard about y'all yeah right
from it let me just ask a question real
quick related to that
how easy or hard is it for them just to
move states that they want to
like because i don't have any problem
with money yeah
i mean it's not that hard that's crazy
that's what i'm saying like
their biggest their basic their biggest
risk is talent loss
and one of the evaluations is how much
are there people happy with living in
california right that's california's had
egress that's what i'm saying like
at the end of the day it like i said
again i'm just looking at a
initial emotionality and if they
that was the gut response to the to the
accusation to the initial claims by the
state of california i'm just
interested to see if they're going to
take it there if it's going to go
there that's the question they're like
hit up everyone that's necessary and ask
them how much do they have
how much is living in california worth
to you
it's yeah this is it's a long one guys i
think that's just what i'm scared of i'm
scared that all this is gonna go out
people and get their coins
yeah and then in six months from now
people okay it's been enough time let's
get back to it like
i don't want that to your point uh cog
we're desensitized to most of this stuff
now because you've seen so much of it
yeah
and we just hope that um with the legal
aspects
yeah it's um it's not necessarily a
band-aid you get the settlement it goes
quiet
but unless the transformation happens
within the individuals who are
at the leadership level you're going to
see that leadership move
move from one place to another and then
the culture may be you know
uh yeah scenarios may happen
valid points great discussion maybe
we'll get lucky and you know
that this has been so public this time
where our actor was just like
we need to stop this uh and they just
have like as because
they probably say behind closed doors
they have zero tolerance for it
but i i it's like i said man i feel like
that there's
there's one or two big people up there
that's keeping the whole car going
you know i understand listen man this is
a great discussion hulk thank you so
much for the
for the knowledge you always you're
always dropping i just want to be
respectful of time because obviously
this
topic i gave you extra you knew i would
i know
but i always feel guilty because i know
you got things going on and i want to
respect andrew as well
we know how how valuable your time is
yes that was good man i'm going to be
watching his videos i love stuff like
that especially deep dive so one hour
in 20 minutes that's not even long for
me that's like 10 minutes
first of all thank you for spending the
time we really appreciate you
you know the lord resonate evil thank
you
you lost that poll sir all right listen
listen i don't care about it another
point
another point that i need to bring up
that i forgot any time you got a fight
you lost resident evil copied off of
alone in the dark so they came first oh
my gosh
the lord of the dark is the goat long
dark was
just quick question you need to send me
one of those like one of those things he
keeps
yeah he didn't send me one i went out
and got it he went and got himself
get back to his family and anybody else
that has to leave now we have to give
them the problem
so lord hogue where can five people find
you what else do you got going on
sir absolutely well i do virtual
legality on youtube by the hoglaw
youtube channel and you can find me on
twitter
you would have seen some of the thoughts
in that video in a late night thread
uh when it happened uh because
fortunately virtually galilee has enough
subscribers now that if
activision gets sued by the state of
california my phone would not stop
beeping
you know if you follow me on twitter
you'll get some of the early thoughts
that'll appear on the video uh but
otherwise that's what i'm doing i'm
doing videos on
the business and law of technology video
games other things that interest me
um and uh we're having a good time there
we continue to grow and it's
been a fun trip keep going i love it you
got me watching loki
i said hogue likes something i'm like
he's so critical i'm like i gotta watch
low-key
player hope said loki was his favorite
mcu tv show but it's a low bar
it's not saying much that mcu disrespect
we're going to talk about this
i think we'll answer i'll be on that
show because i wish they were doing
better than me
i think what makes your content so
unique is
i see other people breaking stuff down
yeah but i don't really see people
breaking stuff down like you
yeah and then you know because i like
doing the tick tock thing like
i see more people in your reign over
there than i ever see on youtube i feel
like
i don't know why i feel like there's not
a whole lot of like you know centric
law channels you know it's just he's got
he's got a gift and a passion for it and
like i said when he'll get into his
legalese bag it's fun to watch because
he's just flowing
i literally listen like smiling i'm
laughing because i can tell the passion
it's cool to see me we do need to start
being really consistent with the r and r
yeah for sure for sure we got to get
back to it below hope enjoy your day sir
appreciate it thank you very much thank
you for inviting me i'm sure i'll be on
again
of course you already know now lord
andrew lance i know we do have one more
topic i just want to be mindful
with your tags i know we are approaching
are you good or
where yeah i i could definitely do uh
the one more time
i appreciate you guys you guys you guys
are amazing thank you for hanging out no
doubt appreciate shout out for one more
and
one bad mothers wanna make sure we good
in the realm sir
yes sir all right no doubt now solve you
want to do on super chat now you want to
wait until
the end don't get asked are we like yeah
you you
um first off uh big shout out
to akeezy williams for a nice little
gift that he has for the realm i'm about
to drop something in the
chat right now first one to get it yes
go get it go get it
all right go get it go get it go get it
go get it
what song and so this code courtesy of
lord of kizi williams
is for the new hotness death store oh
on the xbox platform so don't get that
no doubt
a little get that hotness man i was
about to drop my death door in there
king you cannot enter so leave that
alone
yeah because i don't think this last
topic is going to take yeah
last one man um this is i believe kings
but i'll set it up for him yeah man um
10 cent 10 cents out here oh 10 cent
steps up
british video game developer sumo 1.3
billy well one point two seven well one
point two seven you're correct one point
two seven so
we we rounded up we rounded it but uh
yeah so it's good it definitely is out
there um
a billion with a b with a b yeah
and i'm gonna give you why mm-hmm in a
second yeah i better hear why
look they just you know um they said i
bought a sumo finally believes the
business will benefit from 10 cents
broad video game ecosystem proven
industry experience
and strategic resources so uh yeah this
has been going around so
i think they are responsible also for
what is it big sac boy
they've done uh
as well and a couple other high profile
range of games so uh
cheesecake i was gonna say keep in mind
i just put a poll in there
okay is is tinsel worth a billion with a
b
[Laughter]
set all right well all right so
um a lot of people are familiar with
sumo digital a lot of people think sumo
digital is like a new company sumo
digital is not a new company they were
info games
you know they were founded in 2003. um
this is 18 years
into the game and this acquiring
um affects more than you think like you
know cog mentioned big sack boy
and um a lot of you guys remember that
they helped finish off
um crack down three paws
um and when you start to look at the
diverse catalog
and the games that they did actually
co-create
uh cold develop and push out the door
these games are outstanding in the sense
that
these i didn't know how far they reach
were
at all i thought you know they just did
smaller games here and they were just
like a
a tie your shoes uh button up type of
company
and it wasn't that they did virtual
tennis for the um
playstation portable yeah they did
outrun uh coast to coast
um extensive history yeah they have a
huge catalog and they work with
microsoft
a lot on a lot of microsoft uh
properties and titles
um they have 700 employees they're from
sheffield
england and when
we worry about microsoft purchasing
companies or we worry about sony
purchasing companies we hear out
cries for this stuff but then
we hear a foreign entity purchasing
these companies
quiet and are you implying that there's
that's a good point
are you going for the boss sir are you
going for the ball yes i'm i'm going for
the fact that
they quo and they have an ability
to keep quiet and move in the shadows
while they keep
acquiring rings they
keep acquiring that gauntlet
you look over hip hop gamer was on the
show
last week and he explained to you for a
long time
10 cent was number one in video game
earnings how did they do that they don't
have a console
how did they do that and they're not a
major
so-called we say the big three right how
come
they're able to do these things and
move and utter secretly and silence
and when you look up you say oh that
company is owned by 10 cent
is this an app and i've rang the alarm a
while ago you've been on it
and i've been saying at what point in
time because their philosophies are not
in line with
uh western philosophies you've been art
right
and a lot of uh practices that tencent
have
allegedly um oriented that whole
influence was lit right
with our western philosophies
when does this stuff become a problem
that they're quite and this company has
a rich
history you know so 1.27
billion dollars is nothing to sneeze at
you have to look at companies that
got acquired for 300 million this is
money
to when i tell you when you go in and
you put down their monies they keep the
change
this is keep the change money to shut up
and let's help rip and get this done
yeah i have to agree with you they they
have no problem overpaying
right 43 above
market value sumo was purchased by by uh
sumo
that's terrible that was that was that
was we're skipping
we're skipping all of your people they
have no say pay them off
that's what that's what you that's what
you have to do when you purchase
something that isn't necessarily for
sale
right you're overpaid right right that's
what microsoft did was
was that was zenimax worth that much
money no
but that's how it happened how did how
did uh whatchamacallit how to take two
get outbid by
by uh by ea for codemasters right they
just came in they they put that bid in
it wasn't high enough these guys came in
with another one gone
uh yeah but when you understand yielding
later this is nothing to them
yes right correct expansion if this is
about expansion
in the west and you know you're going to
yield later based on the talent that you
have especially
from what you just acquired this is this
is nothing mm-hmm
too right like yeah i think i think king
brings up uh
you know some good questions here and
we've said it before
you know uh or i've heard you say you
said i say we
i was i was in the background you always
do the chat brother
yeah yeah you know that they tencent is
the white walkers right this is really
the final button
my man one bad mother continues speak
brother so you gotta
you gotta ask yourself why would you
overpay so obviously they didn't buy
super digital because they were this
great value
right like that's obvious based on this
so
what is it that the why would you
overpay for a support
studio right now yes and and that's what
sumo is
by and for people who don't know sumo is
actually one of the industries
from what i've heard from people that
that are a little bit more engaged
they're one of the industry's more
important support studios
and they support a lot of people they
you know make games for sega sony
microsoft everybody and um and i was
even you know one time
i asked about well hey it's acquisition
season is this somebody microsoft might
go for and they're like well i hope not
because they're so important to so many
other studios out there
uh that i hope that microsoft doesn't
take them because that
because they are pretty if you took them
off the board
a lot of companies would struggle uh if
that wasn't
a go-to for them anymore and you know
when you look at kind of where the
industry has
is is heading right now it is heading to
an area where
um being the market leader isn't who
sells the most consoles it's going to be
being wherever you know the gamers going
to be and i think
10 cent right now is positioning
themselves and this is why you know
you probably have heard you know this is
who microsoft really considers the true
competition
long term uh because as you start
tearing down those walls where you know
the walled gardens and and plastic's no
longer a barrier between
the consumers and and these companies
here um
10 is is acquiring assets to go
head-to-head with everybody and i do
expect they are going to come out with a
subscription like if you look at the um
most analysts say are predicting there's
gonna be a lot of subscriptions
in the next you know five years because
if you follow like even what happened in
the tv industry which is
a much you know smaller industry it's it
and it's losing size compared to gaming
already you know it's already smaller
than gaming and gaming is supposed to
get a lot bigger
um you see netflix paved the way and
what they find out is that it's not a
it's not a winner takes all so you're
going to see a lot of companies jump in
but i think tencent is positioning
themselves and so when people keep
you know like when we focus on the
acquisitions and you know it's
acquisition season who's microsoft going
for
it's not really about keeping things
away from sony i really think right now
it is their focus on wherever 10 cents
sniffing i
you have to assume that's that microsoft
is
is kind of trying to be in that in those
conversations too so
uh right now these companies are when
you see this
quote-unquote consolidation in an
expanding industry um
this is all about where this industry's
heading and we know five years a lot's
gonna happen
and five years is nothing that's that's
the that's the development of one game
and so that's what that's what's
happening right now so i'm expecting
um you're going to see other you
the market is is heating up pretty fast
and so i i think you're going to see a
lot more happen soon no i agree
um andrew i know if i got your thoughts
on this one without sensing sort of make
sure
if he stepped out it's cool um let's get
let's get attic man wait wait yeah
i don't care about slow-mo you don't
care about sumo slo-mo
slo-mo yeah
i feel like this is more about tencent
being an issue than
than uh than this company being bought
if they can come out out of all the
companies we can think of like you know
obviously they didn't
they spent half of what microsoft spent
on minecraft
on this company so like what makes you
think that they won't do
this like you know they bought 40 above
once if it was a company that they
really wanted you know what i'm saying
like
this seemed like they just walked in
like we kind of want them
but we want to make sure no one else
buys them so here's the bag
we skip in the line but once if it comes
to like a cd projekt red
where it's like we want them here's a
bag
don't go anywhere else i feel like
that's the bigger
issue is i think
they're moving in ways they're
one bad mother hit the nail on the head
how do you [ __ ] an industry
you from take out the support yeah
if sumo is this the go-to yo we got a
game that we got to finish
let's call sumo if if this
let's call sumo we almost finished with
this project how we can get this
let's call sumo if you remove
somebody's support system you [ __ ]
those individuals
in a stance that they're not able to
operate and move
in the same manner that they were before
and they
lose that support i didn't think about
it until you said it sir
i don't know utterly amazing because
good to you
it's like at the end of the day it's
like you know
it would be different if i knew it ended
here but i know it's not going to end
here
right you know tense in six months from
now who knows
tenson is dropping the bag like that
tension is the kind of money
that microsoft's like we ain't even
trying to buy tencent ever
like that's that's that's that wouldn't
happen
well you get what i'm saying like i'm
talking about like volume and how big
the company is it's like
even companies like microsoft's like
they're out of our price range
like you know what i'm saying like like
and tits is just looking at the feelings
it's like
because they're not a platform owner
everything's on the field
right because they don't have to answer
to any kind of consumer base
because they can low-key stay in the
shadows because that's where they are
they're in the shop yes
they can do anything they want they
don't have that can i ask you a question
do you think because they don't own a
platform that they're able to
operate in the shadows in a manner that
they're doing yeah because look
they just bought this company and if it
would have been microsoft or sony
sony a little bit less than microsoft
they would have got they would have got
coverage saying that this is bad for the
industry okay this thing buys it
and they're like no one bats an eye i
don't i didn't see one person say this
was a bad thing that valid not one
person
not in the same way not at all in the
same way you know
if king rang the bell recently again i
rang
i i rang this bell years ago you did
yeah
it was i don't remember the this was
like maybe 2018 that was the first
when they first came in and
the thing about it is that they they
move
as sheep but they're wolves
and the reason they're wolves is because
whenever they acquire something
they don't change it right they don't
come in they're not disruptive in that
way
they purchase they give support right
they give support yeah but but to date
they haven't done
anything with anything that they
purchased they just here's money here's
support
there's been there's you know what's
crazy allegations
there's been subtle changes on when it
wait
i have bars let me say something real
quick real quick slow slow-mo you know
what is with you today you'll you'll
find out what's it was slow-mo here in a
minute okay
imagine this no no i was actually
thinking
imagine this two years down the line
tencent teams up with an american
company and they publish their own
console
and then all these properties they've
been buying and all these things that
they've been doing
automatically comes exclusive like
there's so many i don't think that will
ever happen because i think tens is
making
too much money but this is not being a
platform
the gaming stuff right the gaming stuff
doesn't matter
it's just a way for them to get in i
don't really think they care about the
gaming stuff
that's what i'm saying i'm saying that
we're always talking about
like apple coming into the into the
gaming industry and
amazon the only company i could truly
see that could do something is tencent
because they own half the industry
right but that would that would slide
in without making the noise forget what
i'm saying you get what i'm saying
though like i'm not saying they're
making a console would put them too far
into the public eye right right
and they they're not going to want to do
that they're already because of the
acquisitions that they made they're
already catching the
ire of i'm not their own government i'm
not i'm not
saying that they are going to do with
themselves i said they're going to
partner with someone
they wouldn't do it either i don't know
man i i feel like you you think that
apple's got
the i feel like you you you publicly
support someone and you you have it's
it's kind of like what they're doing now
they got their foot and everything what
is
what is going out of their way and
funding a system and having another
company do it and just being a silent
partner
i think i think it's interesting to
watch because the names that they're
adding to their rolodex without
being public is amazing it's amazing
crazy people don't realize what they owe
oh let me yeah
i think i think that's that's the the
focus because
it's one thing to i mean consoles are
great and we know we're getting
additional handhelds you know
at some point i think that's fantastic
but when you can move that
quietly and acquire new names to your
rolodex that are connected to some of
the major companies that we
enjoy today or we have enjoyed over the
years that's saying a lot about
your strategic partnership um acumen
when you're doing those things and i
think it's amazing to watch
when we don't even know what's happening
this is ridiculous
like i'm looking at this they own a
hundred percent of riot games
a hundred percent of phone call liu so
there's a lot of you know uh
cub uh companies that make the games
over there they own
they are what remedy they owe discord
they owe
stuff in discord they own stuff in
roblox
i bet you they got in that real soon
they own five percent of ubisoft they
own
five percent of activision and blizzard
they own sumo uh
sumo now like it's just crazy and what's
funny
i don't see but this time next year the
year after i expect this list to be
doubled
do you i can't even name i can't even
name one person that works there
yeah yeah do you remember do you
remember um when ubisoft was trying to
when uh vendi was trying to take over
use off
and and they came to the rescue and got
[ __ ] up
in the back and got five percent they
came to the rescue not get them out of
here
we don't get very political here right
mm-hmm i know where you're going
but the fact of the matter is that there
there are other interests at play here
and and how their ideologies and i'm
talking about the government of china
not the people
not the people here government of china
and how their ideologies
differ greatly from our own yep uh
the fact that they this business has
been so pervasive
in our business um is
troubling because we're giving money to
them and they're in exchange they're
giving business and money to us
that uh kind of makes a lot of people
push aside
their sort of personal feelings and and
and and
things get more right and more moral
yeah their moral compass is is spinning
just like this 43 percent above valkyrie
could do that
yeah it's just
it's a it's it's a little scary did you
imagine
and i just got equated to this would you
imagine you have your house on the
market and somebody comes and they
pull up already
and they tell you oh you can stay there
yo stay there you stupid yeah
terrified i'm terrified i move out the
next day but
but then kicks my windows to red
no no red window for you we we changed
that back they're like
they're more like blue they're they're
they're more like that
they're like i want to change my windows
to red well how much you want to change
windows
[Music]
you have to look at the mindset of the
individual
handing you money to make sure that
you're okay
and say i don't want nothing right now
we're good
but it will come back like you you don't
think it's going to come back it's going
to come back at your
worst moment yep your worst because you
thought that moment was your worst
moment it
actually wasn't the most moment was when
you accepted it
look we get let me get into it i don't
it's like bungie i know it's
like when they made the deal of
activision they thought it was their
best thing at that time
a couple years down the line they're
like okay maybe
great topic um this is very interesting
um yeah like remember how the joke was
like with all the studio acquisition i
was calling it cuff and season you got a
wife
yeah you're gonna say whatever whatever
but you know and at the time
you know we we were hearing a lot of
pushback you know oh
you know i don't i don't like microsoft
doing this and and sony doing you know
whatever but but apparently microsoft uh
we would hear that
right and and look like soft said you
know we here in abroad
we really stay away from the political
stuff we do you know i'm saying that's
not we don't choose to make this
form but this we cannot avoid some
aspect of what's going on here right
and the thing that is concerning like we
said you know is that that
that moral compass obviously from each
studio head when let's say if you're
going under or if you're not even going
on if you're on the market
and then like king said the limousine
pulls up and someone's giving you
you know this new shooter that's given
you way more than everyone else's market
value right
that is an individual decision at that
point that you have to make as a studio
head
am i taking that money and what comes
with that
right that's the first thing then the
second thing is obviously we've been
hearing
rumblings of of crytek right now you
know what i'm saying in them in the mix
to addict's point they have their
tendrils and a lot of things
and it people have to be cognizant of
how
much and it's it's so weird because
there's so much they have but
it's still like like king said it's like
it's it you don't really know it's
a dog like it it seems almost random
it's almost random but it's like
the thing is this you know it's not
exactly and the thing is
it's something it's worth monitoring my
my thing is this
i'm always pro developer i'm always
going to be on the side of
you know these games are i want the
developer to be able to create what they
want to create
free of restriction to me that is always
the stance i'm going to lean on
however we have seen instances already
from those who are being acquired
by 10 cent even in subtle ways in
certain
aspects of their video games whether it
be call of duty
guilty gears drive certain things that
they wanted to
put in their game that that government
associated with tencent did not
that's removed yes without question
you you're not putting you know why yeah
you took the money
exactly so so be cognizant
developer studio ahead that if you take
that bag
there's something that comes with that
you know i'm saying and that's my only
thing it's like
that is gonna challenge the structure of
a lot of studios or certain things so
look
i ain't pocket watching you take that
bag
great money's crazy i'm pocket walker
don't take that man
that's a personal decision but know what
comes
with that bag you don't say because
they're out here and at the end of the
day like i said
they they have influence you know say in
in reference to their government and
stuff like that so you you got to be
careful this is something like king said
yeah i think it's only the beginning man
yeah we're within them yeah yeah i mean
we've talked about how the nba has been
influenced by this we talked about
the fact that john cena was made to
apologize i apologize
bro you don't realize exactly what's
happening until it's true
until it's too late right and and if you
and if you see it happening
and you don't speak up about it you just
got to understand that
when sony makes a purchase there's a big
hoopla
when microsoft makes a purchase there's
a big hoopla
if nintendo makes a purchase there's a
big hoopla
if 10 cent makes a purchase it's a
byline yeah like
nobody's outraged nobody's like they're
controlling the new one
fact bro it's funny you say that because
it's not just
gaming media as well there's certain
aspects they they
all purchased by yes their tendrils
are in a lot of things and it's up to us
to be cognizant
of that and it's up to the developer and
all the entities to be cognizant of
what happens when you sign that specific
paper if i ever learned anything from
warren buffett is if you control
the media you control the narrative yeah
that's a good point but that's all i
love those glasses at it you know
i'm done with you yo you know he's he's
done that yeah
let's get the poll and then we'll get
everybody out just get out of here his
attic is clearly he's he's ready to go
uh new
new london i'll be informed it should be
up on launching gaming.net right now
so it's courtesy of selectbang007 of our
patreon tier salute to him
if and when phil dominus
maximus aurelius spencer's time is
up as the head of xbox who do
you think should take his place as the
rightful successor
to the throne that's an interesting poem
great question did choices
that's easy hey the queen sarah bond
yeah that's what i was going to do
the deacon pete hines
no siege god howard
no or d anyone who bends the knee and
anyone who apologizes is not acceptable
or d i'll let y'all finish but dog
patrick is one of the best xbox
ones
those are the questions please rock the
ball and paul it's up right now on
lawrencegaming.net
but first let us salute the amazing
lord andrew alliance rocked out with us
the whole time
tremendous gaming history tremendous
discussions i mean man the intellectual
stuff the meta stuff the
life and passion and gaming and journey
but brother yes
he's he's talking about empowerment
empowerment just have to listen to his
words
amazing so where can the fine people
find you and what do you have going on
sir
absolutely man you can find me on your
eye you are iyya that's where most of my
stuff uh
is posted i have a multi-link in there
if you guys are interested in learning
about crypto i have a crypto journal
in there nice post that post that multi
link in there hustle if you're still in
the chat yeah
yeah we take care of continue brother
yes so i have a crypto journal in there
i've been um
really diving back into the
cryptocurrency space so i wasn't there
since uh
in 2017 kind of dipped out and back in
full force and investing in a lot of
different companies and stuff like that
so
i have financial literacy in there all
the way to mining
i was mining earlier some coins and
stuff like that so yeah so i'm in that
space
pretty heavily but uh the podcast was on
hiatus because you know we had some live
things that we're situating
um specifically with me okay um but um
the shuttle radio
uh the show radio and four you can find
the podcast there we almost have 600
episodes
um and we're pretty proud of the
conversations that we've had over there
with a lot of individuals uh for sure
but yeah most of my links are on my
my twitter and that's where i update my
system no doubt i put the twitter up in
there again again please support this
brother really
solid content well i like again it's
very very introspective you always give
your passion and i love that you a lot
of productivity videos where you really
help other content creators try to
improve in different aspects just as a
concentrated also on the tech side
i could use your help yesterday my
keyboards failed but that's a good story
but look how did you go and gave your
keyboard man i appreciate you bro
like love but yeah we love to to shine
on people like you because again
you see the journey you see the growth
and you're doing great things you know
we'll have you back
in the realm once again alliance my man
andrew what's up man salute
we love love let me hear from you man
and of course
making his debut as well cameo
that we've been working on for some time
so apologies
what that brother you you podcast with
uh the world's first xbox live
uh beta tester shout out to brad but you
also
do some amazing writing with xbox era
and those guys but i want to salute you
one bad mother thank you for
pulling up where can i find people find
you what else do you have going on
yeah first off uh mr cognito and the
rest of the iron lords
thank you so much it was awesome being
on the show i've been watching you guys
since um
gosh since you were able to read the the
patrons in like a short period of time
so you know and i remember actually it's
funny i was talking to enrique about
this like on the phone
uh one day i was like you know like when
i first heard you guys i was like
there was something special about you
guys and i i remember talking to other
people
and it was like like i can't wait for
people to
discover you know iron lords
it's it's great to see you guys getting
discovered and just just growing like
this
and you've been a group that i've been
rooting for for a while
um you know in fact you know
one of the reasons this is pretty
special to me is is this group is
actually
what kind of inspired me to maybe want
to move forward
in this in this industry like as a as an
influencer or
just getting involved in in uh you know
writing about it
and the reason is is you really brought
back you know listening to you guys it
just brought me back to like those days
where
you know me and my guys would be sitting
around the second genesis you know
talking trash you know with the drinks
on a weekend or
or going up to the bowling alley and you
know
so you know and just hearing these
stories too
you know it's one of those things that
like even hearing like andrew's journey
and
hearing different people's journeys it
it it's not
just it you know it's not just gaming
it's life and
and and it's great that you guys uh you
just
bring back that kind of love and family
and and
you know use gaming as something that
brings people together you know before
remember back in the day when we used to
circle around those those systems we
didn't ask people too much about like
we didn't really care right we you were
all invited we just all kind of got
there and i think that you bring that
back and it's and it's important thing
so thank you brother that means a lot
man
you know and and to hear you know you
know people like yourself
and people who say hey you know you know
it's one thing to do something
and believe in it that's why i like
andrew's quote you know i'm saying it
was kind of it really
the whole like you know believe in your
vision even though when others don't see
it kind of deal
it was like that for us too because we
believed in it it just for whatever
reason at the time it just wasn't
you know we weren't getting the eyes
that we thought we kind of deserved a
little bit and
you know one thing for me i can speak on
you know king or king always believe
let's just get that a king
was always that the visionary it was no
wavering with this man but you know
there was times the content created i
was like damn you know what i mean attic
talk like damn so
you know like this this is good content
no one's not feeling us like what what
do we got to do
and i think the only thing i could
resonate is that just still believing it
and like yo i don't care
i still enjoy doing this we still enjoy
doing this you know what i'm saying and
you know i mean sometimes yes when it
comes oh my
i don't like that couch bro come on sit
down sit down
sit down and tell me where it hurts let
me talk to you
so you say look look like imagine you
sitting in that chair tell me how you
feel carl
sometimes you need that couch man no
problem sometimes
it's like i said sometimes when it comes
to stuff like that you just
sometimes you just gotta restructure
feel you know do stuff that you're doing
you know
when we come to having stuff like um
what's what i'm looking for uh what's
his name uh
you know reach out to your community man
get get different people coming in
get different audiences coming in uh
upgrade the equipment
you know not everyone
like cares whether or not you look
crispy clean or you sound crispy clean
uh clear but sometimes you know people
do you can miss that audience if you
don't have it
so yeah no not for sure but thank you
for that
one bad boy it meant a lot you know
because again we hear stories
of people that listen to us and it was
there from you know early in
the season on our little journey respect
for sure
and i do want to also say like that is
something too that i think about like
watching you guys kind of
grow over the time and i said hey these
guys are already big but they just
haven't been
people haven't seen you know just need
to see them first
and like i keep that in mind too like
even with our team
and you know over at xbox there we were
group of guys that
you know uh it was founded by nick and
johnny you i know you've been on the
show with nick before
and um you know it but it was a group of
guys that were like in a discord and
and you know we kind of just came
together organically you know i know
playstation fans like that
so we can just kind of group organically
but it's one of those things is that you
know if
you feel like you're doing the right
things and you're you're starting to
you know you start to believe in what
you're putting out there you know those
the the numbers will come right right
you know it's just focus on
you know first focus on you know you
being the best you and growing
and eventually all that other stuff will
kind of take care of itself sometimes
and i think the biggest thing i could
possibly say
is out of pocket i think the biggest
advice the biggest advice i could give
someone is like
take criticism well man yeah yeah at the
end of the day
sometimes that criticism they give you
might not
you gotta read super chat popcorn though
no my food is ready okay okay
he got a text already like you guys all
right
look lord lord addict
you're you're you're you're you're
you're you're you're you're outro sir
where can five people find you what
you're going on guys in the movie
i know he's not doing too much all right
i'll turn it off
um you know first off appreciate
everyone coming through
um you know i i do right before uh after
we
read the super shots i'm gonna drop some
codes periodically through there
keep keep in mind what's going on in the
chat because i'm gonna put some
questions in the chat and the first
member
the first non-member i'm i'm going to
you know be doing different things in
the chat
while they're reading the super chats
you know we definitely appreciate
everything you guys do that's why i'm
gonna do one for the members in here and
then i'm gonna drop a chat in here
for non-members uh but you know we
appreciate everything you guys do
so what's going to end up happening i'm
gonna throw those in the chat definitely
be paying attention to that i got a
death door
code so we've technically gave away two
deathstore one with
because uh yeah it's great can i get
this one
no no if you wanted it if you want a
dust door you're gonna have to
solve and have him send you a desktop
i will be asking zelda questions in the
chat
in honor of skyward sword but it won't
be related to skyrocket
but i definitely yeah i definitely
appreciate it we will i've had people
ask
a couple questions about the um the the
podcast we're doing we are having
artwork made for it now so
keep that in mind and i have had people
ask me about the the little man it's
coming it's coming
artwork does not artwork is not
overnight it takes time to develop
if we want the best version of it you
guys got to wait i apologize
it's common let's go lord solve with the
five people fires what you got going on
uh
first off one more really quick giveaway
shout out to
member of the realm and the nwa
everwhile for uh providing this code
for three months of xbox game pass
ultimate
but it only works on brand new accounts
so you have if you're in our chat
and you're somebody who has not uh
jumped in
onto the game pass bandwagon this is for
you and if you happen to get it and you
already have game pass
pay it forward to somebody that you know
doesn't have it so i'm gonna drop that
in the chat right now
first one to grab it congratulations no
doubt that's
right new game pass subscribers
and uh yeah for me the big shout out uh
to andrew
to lord hogue obviously one bad mother
for coming through
uh yeah andrew like i just like i said
before i love conversations like this i
love the fact that we're
we'll sit here for two three hours
talking about you know going deep into
into okizami and like fighting game
stuff
and and then deeper real lives real life
stuff so uh
yeah i definitely appreciate you on the
podcast uh and one bad mother you just
keep doing what you're doing my brother
and then ho
coco hogan's just a beast he really is
like hogue is
he takes all of these subjects that a
lot of us don't really understand
on a granular level and just breaks it
down in a way in a way that he knows
that we can uh
yes yeah because we like the layman
and i'm like he goes in and he's all
right let me speak to him but he doesn't
we don't need him we need him he's like
the transcriber
exactly yeah he knows we're peons but he
doesn't treat us yeah he doesn't cheat
us like that yeah yeah he gives you
he gives it to you that you can digest
the no yeah exactly
lord king what you got going on we can
find people find yourself i'm hungry
okay um uh first first and foremost
i will i would like to thank cod thank
you i would like to thank you
because where you going
without your no i was saying he was like
what's it for
without you digging and and and going
and
looking and bringing different
individuals to the podcast that i didn't
know that i needed
um we would definitely be like a [ __ ]
without a rudder
love all right so let me let me just say
thank you
because in his blessings for that
because um
i got a chance to meet a young
individual that is
grounded insightful and
didn't know that i had to look at your
content
because when you come across a study of
men and i just say men in general i'm
talking about man in general i'm talking
about one man man
a study of human
uh that's very rare
you are mindful with the words that come
out of your mouth because you know words
of spelling and spellings
cast spells you understand these things
and you know what that means
you are grounded in your haitian
heritage and you're proud of that and
you
also explain your story through and we
walk the same streets
we've been in the same stuff and it's
beautiful to see your journey
and you growing and you giving reverence
to an individual and you didn't even
understand
that it was happening subconsciously
when you were doing it
i believe that's how i went maybe maybe
i'm just connecting dots
but it was a real treat today
yeah a real treat today to meet you
to hear your story and to connect with
you
so i do appreciate everything and even
if you didn't get a chance to talk about
the cryptocurrency you put that there
for people to go
find those nuggets because if they
really want to dig they will get to your
content
and dig and find out more and i
appreciate that and i appreciate
what you're trying to do and what you
are doing
because when you did say they asked you
what was
your pinnacle point you said you could
pull everything
from all the interviews and that was
beautiful
that that showed very good
thoughtfulness in
what you were saying one bad mother
you have been around a lot
and when you popped in i was like one
bad mother's in here
and and and this is why i love the
community
we have support from individuals that's
been around and you've been around and i
know this
mm-hmm i've seen that name i remember
when that name first said it i was like
oh
and to hear you talk you
you have stuff to offer our community
is rich and it's vast and it's such a
beautiful thing that keeps giving back
don't dismiss anyone don't ever fax and
and on the road not bad um try to stick
around for after super chats because i
have a question
i want to thank hope for coming in yes
and
you know giving something that we don't
understand because none of us here are
lawyers
he's a lawyer he he knows how to read
those paragraphs it looks like gibberish
his body will be hieroglyphics right it
might as well
but we're going to go off a pure emotion
about yeah he's right yeah he
and he balances it yeah he balances it
and
gives you expectations that are in
reasonable forms
and he allows you to understand it and
allows you to digest it's a reason why
we
went with hoglar to help us achieve our
llc
because we trusted him and believed
in that man who is honest and real
yeah he's a real one yeah where is he
based on
michigan yeah michigan but he again if
we'll talk offline if you're looking to
do this yeah and he will also
refer you to other people as well like
we tremend this rapport with him
and yeah like i said he he's just a
genuine individual
and ultimately it seems like a wholesome
dude oh yeah
ultimately to king's point another the
reason is and solve would understand is
some other entities that we went to
didn't even understand what a podcast in
the video game space
is yeah so we wanted someone that had a
feeling a true knowledge of the culture
before
you know somebody that actually respects
the resident evil's the goat
um
i already have it in the queue already
did everything uh hip-hop game is in
that episode too as well
um but thank you guys everybody that's
here you know like share
you know subscribe if you haven't
already uh
send it out to a friend but also go to
lords of gaming.net
um we have a ton of writers there we
have
a lot of stuff that goes on and a lot of
news we
break they source us
so go there i know you heard me with the
ign
stuff yeah we just as big
you got to respect it the house was real
listen tremendous show this was
wow this is a very deep show i didn't
expect that but loved it you know the
the different perspectives everything
was great again shout out to hulk for
pulling up
blessed us with his time busy day if i
didn't even come through a drop blessing
with any knowledge as much appreciate
lord andrew alliance i'm so glad we are
working together i'm looking to work
more with you in the future
i think more people need to hear about
you hear from you the content is great
please subscribe to his channel he's got
andrew lyon's channel he's got the show
you know what i'm saying radio a great
podcast and again
my bro what that mother you know i said
good good to see you man good to see you
i love
what you're doing and and me and you
talking offline and again i really
appreciate the kind words because
it it it truly shows you know sometimes
you don't realize you have
we touch people you have been brought up
a few times in conversations
yeah facts facts and i'm i like to see
what you're doing and salute to the team
you're with
you know what i'm saying obviously brad
and lord lord try and collect that
himself he'll get him back in the realm
as well
it's been a minute and of course slow
for forte the whole crew
um ej eric jackson b money all those
guys over there
basement radio arcade podcast but look
great show y'all that's all i
got addict you out of dating business
before we get up out of here oh yeah
we didn't even do super chat
so look this is what we're going to do
out of fairness to those here
we got a business to do so if you guys
can you can take off because i know
you're the king's got to eat
i'm dying right now yeah they keep super
chatting on purpose
if you got it please we have business so
if you got to go it's all good all good
do your salutations i appreciate y'all
just i just want to say thank you man i
love y'all i love your content
i know blessings to you guys um i'm
about to eat also
you've given me a lot to think about and
you guys are a blessing in the space so
thank you so much thank you
thank you thank you much love solve
let's take care of business
and uh real quick real quick um
we i i did i forgot to mention we we're
six away
from our next stream six six uh sub six
members but that's fine
and real quick before uh we hand it off
to super chats i have a question for the
members
in the chat the first member to post the
the
the answer to this will win a game uh
and the question is what instrument did
link find gandalf playing
after confronting him in ocarina of time
if
[Laughter]
is the monster that gandalf turns into
gandalf is the actual person oh
ganondorf
ganondorf yeah ganondorf no it's not a
flute
all right so you got that in there cool
yeah yeah i'm just going to give it to
the first person who says it's not a flu
it's not it gets hard
really i can't there you go okay hit me
up on um
uh hit me up on on twitter what's your
twitter
lord addict iop all right and it's like
i said we we are seven away
from doing our next stream from neither
members or
patreon no doubt no doubt saxophone i'm
done with it i'm dealt with yeah the
trump
yeah will be loose his beads we lose too
but look we gotta pay the bills on
let's get to it all right uh
we got tony bryant five dollar super
chat this show definitely for oh i got
that one optimus code with the 50
super chat no need to read this but of
course we're going to read it thank you
brother great content as usual proud of
you brothers y'all have no idea thank
you my brother
much appreciated code appreciate it i
like behave code
i don't know who that other dude is on
twitter i like to do
on podcasts and he jumps in the chat i
like him
salute the code and we got fat boy
horror five thousand
chat glad dez faces back but ea is still
a punching bag
dodgy mts as surprise mechanics and next
gen upgrades for extra cross
nah yeah they they're about that money
you know
cowboys fan 404 10 super chat one bad
mother out here looking like a mix
between solid rev and phil spencer
[Laughter]
fyi all white people don't look like fyi
yes i'm gonna do this on that one
[Music]
there we have flame with the five
dollars well hey at least people cared
for dead space in comparison to a couple
recent remake slash remasters
then we have don otaku with the ten
dollars of the chat
it's crazy that ea has three of my
favorite games this year it takes two
uh knockout city and mass effect
legendary edition
also looking forward to lost in random
and dead space remake never would have
guessed that last year
yeah i mean they're taking they're
bringing back
you know single-player games that people
want to play so let's see
mr irishman 10-pound super jack hearing
twinkle twinkle little star in that
trailer gave me goosebumps dead space is
the greatest survival horror game ever
made
not even re4 holds a candle to it bring
on the remake
told y'all jesus man and we have
uh cowboys fan 404 again 10. almost
forgot andrew alliance out here
looking like the young sticky fingers
from honor
yes yes hip hop heads know what i'm
talking about
for sure then we got hard to find five
dollars at the chat
king just has bad opinions on
heavyweight champs remember what he said
about tyson
even defenders i just i just dropped
borderlands 3 in the chat
nice whoever snatches that first you see
rewards
for sticking with us all the way there
you go uh then we got random citizen
five dollars a chat ari made it a
hotline dead face made it a hot song
that's right baby and remember
ari didn't read nothing oh my god a load
of the dogs the goat now yes
just first yes uh rrd 2000
chat defining duke plus iop six
hours of lord cog can't go wrong
absolutely yeah that dude episodes out
there i have
not listened to it yet that's gonna be
my my work uh
episode hashtag fire deed for those that
get to the end
then we got harget chennai ten dollars
for chat accountability should be forced
by gamers
not engaging with activision blizzard
but consumers always let things go
yes we do do you think gamers will hold
themselves accountable in this case will
you guys
uh the fact of the matter is it's a good
question but i'm gonna tell you right
now
none of us vote with our wallet to that
extent that's what i'm saying
at the end of the day i've always stated
public outreach
on twitter they care more about their
brand than money most the time
yeah so honestly it'll probably directly
more so hurt the developers the ones
that we don't want to hurt
than the actual bottom line of the
company so
there are other ways i just got you got
to talk about it you got to you got to
make it known that the entire industry
both on the fandom side and on the press
side is not going to go for it
and hopefully that begins to move the
the needle a little bit
i forgot we got evan ten dollar super
chat i grew up adoring blizzard until i
worked for them in what should have been
a dream esports job in south korea
it's so crushing to see that it extended
to the rest of the company in my home
country wow
see and we have four eyes malone two
dollars per chat
great show y'all intriguing the whole
way thank you sir thank you
so then we got the rubber knob with the
10 super chat
morning lords this days back to last
week did i hear hip-hop gamer leaked
that the next e3 dance moves jim ryan is
going to walk out on stage and announce
tv tv i just finished watching that uh
e3
xbox where they said tv so many times
continue shout out to hip-hop though
hip-hop is a real
dude yeah very passionate everyone
should go support him
yes sir then we got clutch man five
dollar super chat great intro ready for
the topics joe can't wait for flight sim
to change console gaming forever no
doubt
then we got flame two dollars with a
chat another one and another one and
another
flame trying to incite something yeah we
know what he doing
yeah everybody's just as tired as we are
yeah so i think that's it we're good we
caught up all right cool we believe so
so look so i'll be attica you go oh he
was in the bushes so
i'm assuming he's good so look again
great show y'all we will be
back next sunday more fun more
great guests and things cooking cannot
wait attic you're back anything else
before we're about to get up out here
no i i just you know i want to thank all
the guests and i i really want to thank
all of you you guys come here every week
even
we can all agree the gaming right now is
mad drive
and you guys come in here because you
want to hear our opinions on some of
this stuff
uh and you know king being messy be
fraudulent when it comes to resident
evil but
i definitely i want to thank all of you
for showing up no doubt no doubt and on
that note everybody enjoy your sunday
and until next week
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you